IN FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE'S
ONE AND THREE WILL COME TO
ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SENATE HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND THE ONE
HERE TODAY IN THE CAPITAL. OUR
MEMBERS COULD BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY ALL
THE MEMBERS OF BOTH SUB
COMMITTEE SIR HERE WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF SENATOR MELENDEZ
WHO IS UNABLE TO ATTEND. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR
AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS SIX
FIVE OLD. 407-428-4429 ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR ACCESS SIX FIVE
OH FOUR ZERO SEVEN FOUR. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
REFER TO THE SENATOR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIGHT TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS TO ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. SO MOVING
TO THE- DURING HAVING A JOINT
HEARING THIS MORNING OF
SUBCOMMITTEES ONE ON EDUCATION
AND THREE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
PART EIGHT OF THE AGENDA WILL
COVER CROP CHILD CARE ISSUES
THAT SPAN MULTIPLE. AND FALL
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF BOTH
SUBCOMMITTEES ONE AND THREE DUE
TO THE TRANSITION OF MOST CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
PURSUANT TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET AGREEMENT.
AS A REMINDER THESE HEARINGS
ARE LARGELY INFORMATIONAL
DESIGN TO ALLOW FOR DISCUSSION
OF ISSUES AND TAKE FEEDBACK.
INFORM ACTIONS THAT. NOW WILL
BE TAKEN LATER IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS IN APRIL OR
MAY. OF FOR SUB ONE THIS IS
FOURTH IN THE SERIES OF EIGHT
FEBRUARY HEARINGS WITH THE
FIFTH ONE TOMORROW MORNING. AND
AT THE CONCLUSION OF AGENDA
PART DAY WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE ITEMS AND
THEN WHEN WE'RE DONE WILL.
CHURN THE JOINT SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING SUBCOMMITTEE THREE WILL
THEN. RECONVENE AND CONTINUE ON
TO PART B. AFTER A THIRTY
MINUTE BREAK BETWEEN PART A AND
PART B. AND JUST TO CLARIFY.
SINCE HER BUDGET PREVIOUS
BUDGET ACT TRANSFERRED PROGRAMS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION IS WITHIN THE
JURIDICTION OF SUB ONE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF SUB
THREE IT GETS COMPLICATED BY
THE FACT THAT IF THERE'S ANY
EARLY ACTION THOSE THINGS FALL
BACK TO SUB ONE. OTHERWISE IT
GOES THERE ARE STILL ONE PART
THAT'S REMAINING WITH SUB ONE
THAT THE ONLY WAY TO HANDLE
THIS WAS TO HAVE A JOINT
HEARING AND EVEN THE STATE OF
THE TRANSITION IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING TODAY SO WITH THAT-
SENATOR EGGMAN DO YOU HAVE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS ARE JUST GLAD
TO BE HERE AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER SENATORS WISH TO
MAKE AN OPENING COMMENT.
SENATOR MAN YES I AM I AM NEW
TO THIS PARTICULAR TOPIC AND IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE BUT I DID
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE- WHEN I
WAS A PROFESSOR AT UCI- THE
SCHOOL ALL RIGHT TODD WAS RIGHT
NEXT TO THE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION
AND AS SOMEONE WHO SITS ON SUB
ONE THE EDUCATION SUBCOMMITTEE
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE TALK ABOUT EARLY CHILD
CARE WERE EMPHASIZING THE
EDUCATIONAL ASPECTS OF IT THE
RESEARCH IS VERY CLEAR. THAT
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY AN ISSUE OF
EDUCATION AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T GET LOST
AS WE TALK ABOUT THE NEED FOR
EARLY CHILD CARE I ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS THIS ALL GETS
MOVED OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT NOT.
MAKING THIS A STRATIFIED
PROGRAM ONE THAT IS RESIGNED TO
LOW INCOME PEOPLE BUT- THEY
WERE EMPATHIZING CHILDCARE FOR
ALL FAMILIES- BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S IT
BRIEFINGS TODAY REPORTED
TESTIMONY FROM ALEJO. AND THE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
CENTER GOVERNMENT. WE'RE GOING
TO DO MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE
THE CHILD CARE OVERVIEW. AND
THE PEOPLE. AND IN SOME CASES
WE HAVE. A SECOND PEOPLE FROM
THE SAME. AGENCY AND WILL LEAVE
IT TO THE FIRST PERSON TO
INTRODUCE THEM. IF THAT'S THE
CASE SO IN THIS ISSUE ARE WE
OBSERVE CORTEZ FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND WE HAVE
SERRA BERKNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CARLOS
AGUILERA IS ALSO HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THEN
WE HAVE SERRA NOVEL MORGAN. OF
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER SO WE'LL START WITH-
SARAH CORTEZ AND WILL HOLD ALL
QUESTIONS. TILL AFTER ALL
PANELISTS HAVE PRESENTED. ARE
WELCOME THIS CORTES. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME TODAY SARAH CORTEZ AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. SO IF I WAS ASKED TO
GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
STATE SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. I'LL BE REFERENCING A
FEW FIGURES FROM YOUR AGENDA
FOR THOSE THAT HAVE THEIR
AGENDA HANDY. ON DURING THIS
PRESENTATION. OF THE STATE
SUBSIDIZES SEVERAL CHILD CARE
AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS. THESE
ARE DESCRIBED IN MORE DETAIL ON
PAGE THREE OF YOUR AGENDA. THE
STATE SPEND ROUGHLY FIVE POINT
EIGHT BILLION TO SERVE AN
ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN THE
PROGRAMS LISTED ON PEACHTREE.
BURKE HOW ARE SHALL CARE IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN THE
STATE SIR ALL CHILDREN MEETING
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA. FOR
ALL OTHER PROGRAMS LISTED ON
PAGE THREE THE AMOUNT OF THE
CHILDREN- THE STATE ABLE TO
SERVE IS GENERALLY SET ANNUALLY
BY THE STATE DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS. THE STATE HAS TWO
TYPES OF CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
EITHER VOUCHER BASED PROGRAMS
OR DIRECT CONTACT RAMPS. HOW TO
REACH PROGRAMS PRIMARILY CAL
WORKS HEALTHCARE AND THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM FOR
THESE PROGRAMS- HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS ARE REIMBURSED BASED
ON THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE.
THREE ITSELF IS BASED ON A
SURVEY CONDUCTED EVERY OTHER
YEAR BUT THE STATE DETERMINES
WHAT SURVEY TO USE WE ARE
CURRENTLY USING THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN SURVEY- THE RATE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE VARIES BY
COUNTY ASIAN CHILD SERVED
AMOUNT OF CARE USE AND THE TYPE
OF CHILD CARE. THE TYPE OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDER. FOR THESE
PROGRAMS FAMILIES WILL GAIN
ELIGIBILITY FROM CHILD CARE
WITH THE COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT OR AN ALTERNATE
PAYMENT AGENCY. ONCE THE FAMILY
RECEIVED ELIGIBILITY YOU CAN
USE THE VOUCHER- TO RECEIVE
HEALTHCARE FROM ANY PROVIDER AT
HER FOR HER FIRST IN ANY
SETTING IT PREFERS. WE ALSO
HAVE DIRECT CONTRACTOR FIGHTERS
PRIMARILY EITHER PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM OR THE
GENERAL CHILDCARE PROGRAM.
DIRECT CONTRACT WRITERS ARE
REIMBURSED BY THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SO THIS IS
THE RATE SAID ANNUALLY BY THE
STATE. THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS ADJUSTED
BY AGE THE AMOUNT OF CARE USED-
AND SOME OTHER FACTORS IN MOST
NOTABLY DIFFERS FROM THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE THAT THE
VOUCHER PROVIDERS. ARE
REIMBURSED BASED ON- BECAUSE
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
DOESN'T HAVE A GEOGRAPHIC
ADJUSTMENT. SO THESE PROVIDERS
DRIVE CONTRACT PROVIDERS
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE TO
SERVE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
CHILDREN SO FAMILIES WILL WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE CONTRACTED
PROVIDER TO BECOMING A WORLD IN
THESE PROGRAMS. H. FIVE OF YOUR
AGENDA BEGINS THE DISCUSSION OF
THE PANDEMIC IMPACT AND
RESPONSE ON CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES. CHILL-
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HAVE
REPORTED YOU SURVEYS THAT THEY
ARE SERVING FEWER CHILDREN AND
ARE EXPERIENCING LOSS OF INCOME
DUE TO SERVING LESS SHELTER
AND- PROVIDERS ARE ALSO
EXPERIENCING HIGHER OPERATION
COSTS STUDENT CLEANING
SANITATION. AND PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. AGE SIX
OF YOUR AGENDA HAS SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT LICENSE
CLOSURES- AND ALSO ON PAGE SIX
THERE'S A TABLE OR THE START OF
A TABLE THAT LISTS THE PANDEMIC
RELATED ACTIONS TODAY AND THAT
WERE PRIMARILY TO SUPPORT THE
STATE SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW. WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CARLOS
SECULAR AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND HI MY COLLEAGUES
ARE PARTNER WITH ME AS WELL SO
I JUST WANT TO ADD A LITTLE BIT
TO THE OVERVIEW SENSE. TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE STATE HAS
INVESTED FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING. FOR THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS INCLUDING FUNDING FOR
ONGOING CHILD CARE SLOTS
SUPPORTING TWELVE MONTH COLLEGE
ABILITY IN COVERAGE PROGRAMS
AND A LIMB ELIMINATING NEGATIVE
GROWTH ADJUSTMENTS. MORE
RECENTLY- THE STATE HAS
ALLOCATED NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS TO HELP
REDUCE LONG TERM LOSSES IN ITS
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM DUE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT THERE
IS A SHIFT OF CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- EFFECTIVE JULY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE PROPOSAL
IS TO SHIFT THIRTY THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION FOUR POINT NINE
ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE POINT SEVEN
POSITIONS FOR STATE OPERATIONS.
FURTHER THREE POINT ONE BILLION
OR ONE POINT THREE BILLION
GENERAL FUND WILL BE SHIFTED TO
SUPPORT PROGRAMS FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. THE SECOND PLEASE%
YOUR COMMENTS YES SIR THAT. IS
IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT
NOW WILL MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU TEARS AND MEMBERS
PERINATAL MORGAN DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION PERHAPS THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY. THE AGENDA PROVIDES A
REALLY SMALL OVERVIEW AT THE
EARLY LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIA SO I'M GONNA TOUCH
BRIEFLY ON A FEW SYSTEMS
COMPONENTS TO BUILD DOC WHAT MS
CORTEZ SHARED AND WHAT'S IN
YOUR AGENDA. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY SERVE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
SUBSIDIZED. EARLY LEARNING.
PROGRAMS AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MENTIONED CURRENTLY WE
ADMINISTER BOTH DIRECT
CONTRACTING AND ABOUT YOUR
PROGRAM. S. CONTRACTED PROGRAMS
ARE VERY FOCUSED ON THE
EDUCATION OF CHILDREN AND HAVE
TO MEET PROGRAM STANDARDS WHAT
ABOUT YOUR PROGRAMS PROVIDE
ACCESS TO PRIVATE MARKET
SETTINGS WITH VARYING LEVELS OF
QUALITY. BOTH DIRECT CONTRACTED
PROGRAMS AND CULTURE PROGRAM
SERVES CHILDREN THREE CENTERS
AND YOUR FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES. BROWN'S ALSO SERVE
CHILDREN AND FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR LICENSE EXAM TOM
SETTINGS. THE COSBY MORE ARE
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AS BAD
AS THE PERMANENT WAR REMAIN AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOLLOWING THE
TRANSITION. OUR DATA SHOWS
THERE'S ABOUT HALF A MILLION
CHILDREN AGES THREE AND FOUR IN
CALIFORNIA. AMONG THEM AROUND
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE SERVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL.
PROGRAM FOR ABOUT SIXTY.
PERCENT OF YOUR THREE AND FOUR
WE CURRENT SERVE HUNDRED. ONE
THOUSAND PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. MAYBE NOT A LITTLE
BACK TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALLOCATES A TOTAL OF FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION TO EARLY LEARNING
CARE PROGRAMS ACROSS SEAT AND
THE CHILD AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS. WELL THERE IS A
DECREASE IN THE TOTAL BUDGET
AMOUNT FROM LAST YEAR DUE TO
THE REMOVAL OF ONE TIME FEDERAL
FINES WE APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
MILLION STATE INVESTMENT AND
ONGOING RESOURCES. IS THAT THE
CLEAN WE APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN CURRENT YEAR
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FROM.
RIGHT NOW ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
STOCKS. AS WELL AS THE
ADDITIONAL FORTY FOUR MILLION
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR. SPOTS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR WHILE.
CURRENTLY TO MAKE THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AVAILABLE AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. ALSO WE
APPRECIATE. THE EFFORTS
PROGRAMS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED PROJECT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR PROGRAMMES
DID NOT RECEIVE A CALL LAST
YEAR. IN LIGHT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROUND K.
TWELVE AS WELL AS HOW MUCH YOUR
PROGRAMS ARE STRUGGLING WITHOUT
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
GIVING THEM THE SAME COLOR TO
EARLY LEARNING AS THEY HAVE TO
K. TWELVE. WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO NOTE THAT WE BELIEVE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES IN CAR
WORK SPEECH TO YOU AND THREE.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO GO DEEPER
INTO THOSE ESTIMATES IF YOU.
ALL AS WE LOOK INTO THE NEXT
PHASE OF THIS BUDGET PROCESS WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO ENSURING
ALL CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION
THE BEST SUPPORT THEM IN
REACHING THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
AND ACHIEVING NEST BY ELEVATING
STRATEGIES OUTLINED IN THAT
MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE AROUND HAVING A STRONG
ITS DELIVERY SYSTEM WHICH
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN FOR
UNIVERSAL PRE K. SYSTEM AND
IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICE TO
SAYS THAT SUPPORT EQUITY AND
ALREADY NOW. RESEARCH TELLS US
THAT THE FIRST EIGHT YEARS OF
LIFE ARE CRUCIAL TIME FOR
VALIDATION OR LEARNING. IN THAT
THOSE YEARS HAVE BEEN LINKED TO.
CAPS THAT YOU IN EQUITIES ARE
THAT. SYSTEM AND BEYOND. WOMEN
ARE RESEARCH BY WEST STANDING
UC BERKELEY THERE ARE CHILDREN
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND YOU SAID
SOMETHING CALLED THE DESIRED
RESULTS DEVELOPMENTAL PROFILE
AS WELL AS QUALITY COUNTS
CALIFORNIA. READING OUR
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THE HIGHEST
YEARS IT'S UNIFIED ARE STRONGER
BUT THEY'RE DEVELOPMENTS ON
LEARNING OUTCOMES IN CHILDREN
ARE HERE THREE OR ITS YEAR FOR.
RESEARCH ALSO CLEARLY INDICATES
THAT YOUR LANGUAGE LEARNERS
BENEFIT EVEN MORE FROM ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CSGP
SPECIFICALLY THEIR LEARNING
GAPS WERE NARROWER IN TIER FIVE
THEN THEY WORK OR DO A LANGUAGE
LEARNERS IN TWO YEARS THREE.
SHOWING STRONG RESULTS THE
QUALITY DOES MATTER BURKE
PRESCHOOL CHILDREN. AND NEEDING
TO CONTINUE THEIR- AS A RESULT
IN RETALIATION DESTROYED HIGH
IN THE- BEDROOM. BOTH ONLINE
AND CURRENT PROGRAMS QUALITIES.
ADDRESSING NOT NEED FOR NEXT
DELIVERY. IMPORTANTE QUE
EXTENSION TO OUR LEARNERS
INCLUDING AND NOT ADDRESS THE
RATIO CRITICIZED ANOTHER KEY
COMPONENT. ENSURING THAT WE CAN
BE INCLUSIVE OF ALL CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES AND ALL OF
OUR PROGRAM ELIMINATING THINGS
LIKE EXCLUSIONARY DISCIPLINE
PRACTICES AND STRONGLY
SUPPORTING DOING WHICH LEARNERS.
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS
WE REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH YOU
TO THINK ABOUT HOW THE SCOPE.
ARE MARC LEVINE PRESCHOOL AND
THE TRANSITIONS TO K. K. FIRST
SECOND AND THIRD. DO YOU REALLY
SUPPORT CURRICULUM. ASK THEM TO
BEST SUPPORT LEARNING. AS THE
LAST PIECE AND GOING AFTER SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT MISSED
CORTEZ SHOWED. THE RATES. ON
AVERAGE AS WE LOOK AT OURS
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM THE RATES FOR THAT
PROGRAM. NEED TO GET ME AND
YOUR FROM. ON AVERAGE RULING.
AS CHILDREN ARE IN THE STATE
THE RMR. THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. THE ARE MARKED FOR THE
OTHER PART OF THE SYSTEM IS A
LITTLE UNDER SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
SO IF YOU ARE TAKING YOUR
VOUCHER TO HIRE PROGRAM YOU
WOULD GET ABOUT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND ALONG WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE E.
P. BUT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOUR G. ASKED
ARTIST STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
RATE FOR C. S. P. P. AB. ONE
THOUSAND LAST SPRING. EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE TO MEET HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAM STANDARDS. RCSD
PROGRAMS ALSO SEE SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS PER CHILD THAN A
CHEESECAKE PROGRAM. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ARE PART EIGHTY
K. RECEIVED ABOUT FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND. MARK FOR FRIENDS FOR
CHILD IN THE PARKING YES HE P.
ABOUT HIGHER RATES ACROSS THE
SYSTEM OUR PROGRAMS WILL
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO MEET
THE- GOALS OF THAT MASTER PLAN.
ENGINE AT DRESS THINGS LIKE ART
TEACHER RETENTION AND PAY. YES
THESE ARE ESPECIALLY CRITICAL
IN THAT LIGHT AT THE CHALLENGES
POSED BY COPING NINETEEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY TO ANY.
ANSWER. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF. I'MGOING LEAD OFF WITH A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IN THE FIRST ONE.
MAYBE I SHOULD START WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THEN ASK IF
THE- LA OVER DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS COMMON. VOTE ON IN
OUR AGENDA PACKET IT SHOWS THAT
STAGE TO CAO WORKS CHILD CARE.
IS RECOMMENDED FOR EIGHTEEN
POINT 5% REDUCTION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. COULD YOU EXPLAIN-
WHY THAT'S THE RECOMMENDATION.
MORNINGS A SERVER NOW WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL GO
AHEAD AND START WITH SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE STAGE CHIU CHILD CARE
PROGRAM- BUT NAMELY WHAT WE DO
HERE AT FINANCES THAT WE TRACK
THOSE NUMBERS ARE SIMILARLY TO
WHAT OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE L.
A. OWNS PART OF EDUCATION DO AS
WELL- AND WE ADJUST THE BUDGET
CORRESPONDINGLY TO WHAT WE SEE
HAPPENING TO THE CASELOAD IN
THE COST PER CASE FOR CHILD
CARE AND BOTH THE STAGE TWO AND
STAGE THREE PROGRAM. SO A TREND
THAT WE HAVE BEEN NOTICING FOR
AT LEAST THE LAST YEAR OR TWO
IS THAT THE CASE WILL NUMBER IN
STAGE TWO HAS BEEN GOING DOWN
IT'S BEEN DECREASING AND THERE
ARE CERTAIN POLICY IMPLICATIONS
THAT BECAUSE THAT ON THAT OUR
DEPARTMENTAL COLLEAGUES MIGHT
HAVE A BETTER INSIGHT INTO- BUT
WE SIMPLY ADJUSTS THE BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS BASED OFF THOSE
NUMBERS A STAGE TO HAVE BEEN
DECREASING STAGE THREE HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN INCREASING-
CASELOAD WISE AT LEAST- IN SORT
OF EQUAL AMOUNTS SO IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- THE RECOMMENDATION
AND THE PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE
PUTTING FORWARD IS TO DECREASE
STAGE TWO BY THE TRENDS THAT
WE'RE SEEING AN INCREASE STAGE
THREE. BY A SIMILAR AMOUNT IT'S
ALMOST AND THAT- ZERO EFFECT ON
THE HOW IT WORKS PROGRAMS AS A
WHOLE AT LEAST BETWEEN STAGE
TWO AND STAGE THREE- BUT I'LL
PASS IT OFF TO MY L. A. O. OR
C. CALLING WILL NOT BE JUST
CLARIFY ONE THING SO YOU MAKE
THE RECOMMENDATION BASED ON THE
TRENDS BUT THEY'RE THE ONES
MORE ABLE TO SPEAK TO WHY THE
TRENDS. ARE HAPPENING IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING. WE
SPEAK WITHOUT VERY. A WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN PROGRAM. WE DO.
THE A HARPER. EXPERT PARTNERS-
BUT YOU'RE NOT PREPARED TO
COMMENT ON THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO GET AT YOU YEAH. YOUR
YOU MIGHT TALK TO HIM ALL THE
TIME BUT YOU'RE NOT PREPARED TO
COMMENT ON WHY YOU SEE THE
TRENDS HAPPENING. I'LL
CERTAINLY LET THEM SPEAK TO-
SINCE SPEECH YOUR WHAT'S GOING
ON THE PERSONS THEY HAVE A MORE
DIRECT LINE- TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO PROVIDERS ON THE
GROUND I WILL SAY WHEN WE
DERECHOS CONVERSATIONS WE KNOW
THAT. THERE ARE CERTAINLY A LOT
OF CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE SEEING
IN THOSE PROGRAMS ONE AT LEAST
TRY AND THAT WE'RE NOTICING IT.
EVER SINCE. I WAS TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY WAS INTRODUCED IN
THOSE PROGRAMS. I'LL WE MAY BE
SEEING SOME. SOME FAMILY
STAYING IN THE STATE RUN
PROGRAM THE LONGER AS OPPOSED
TO GOING INTO THE STATE STREET
PROGRAM SO THAT COULD BE PART
OF THE REASON WHY WE'RE SEEING
WHAT WE ARE SEEING. STAGE TWO
OKAY LET ME GO TO THAT LA- WHEN
ASKED IF YOU WOULD COMMENT ON
THAT. WHY DO YOU THINK THESE
TRENDS MIGHT BE HAPPENING- IN
THE ONE THING ALL I- TO. OF
COMMON IS. A THESE ESTá. THAT
YOU KNOW THESE ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES AT
THIS POINT- BUT THE AGREED UPON
ESTIMATES ARE TRYING TO-
PREDICT WHAT CASELOAD WILL BE
IN THE FUTURE SO IT'S BEEN
QUITE. A DIFFICULT TASK IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. I'M WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOME OF THESE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS THAT
HAVE CHANGED ON THE CASE THAT
ESTIMATE SO DRASTICALLY. SO IF
YOU YEARS AGO- AND THIS PARTNER
JUST MENTION TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY SO A FEW YEARS AGO.
WHEN TOLD WITH ELIGIBILITY WAS
IMPLEMENTED- FOR STAGE TWO AND
THREE FIRST- WE REALLY DID SEE.
A STAGE TWO AND THREE CASELOAD
REALLY INCREASE QUITE
DRASTICALLY. I'M IN SO NOW IF
YOU YEARS DOWN THE LINE. TOLD
WITH KNOWLEDGE ABILITY WAS NOT
IMPLEMENTED STAGE ONE. AND
WE'RE WE'RE SEEING- READ THE
DATA REFLECTING THAT THE
STATE'S ESTACIO QUESADILLAS IS
DECREASING. QUITE DRASTICALLY
ALL. YEAH MONITORING THE DATA
SO I THINK IN WORKING. TO LOOK
INTO AND I'M ANALYZE TO MAKE IT
TO ENSURE THAT THE ADMIN.
ESTIMATES REASON. ON THE THAT
STILL WORK AT. WILL CAN TO DO
AS WE AS WE HEAD INTO THE
SPRING. I'M ASKING A MOMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
COMMENT BUT LET ME ASK YOU JUST
ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION IT SEEMS
FROM YOUR ANSWER. THAT YOU'RE
BASICALLY SAYING THESE TRENDS
WERE IN EVIDENCE FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME THAT WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC SO IT'S NOT REALLY A
PANDEMIC IMPACT. THE YOUR
NOTING IS RELATED TO THIS
REDUCTION. YEAH SO- IF SOME OF
IT COULD BE PANDEMICS ARE NOT
QUITE SURE YET TO BE ABLE TO
PARK STYLE KIND OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIKE
PANDEMIC RELATED. ON KEESLER
TRENDS OR PRE PANDEMIC HE SAID
TRYING BUT WE WILL NOTE THAT WE
DID SEE. A DECREASE IN IN CASE
A TRANSCRIPT HAD TO MAKE AND
THEN ONCE A PANDEMIC STARTED IT
DID IT DID. THE TRENDS THAT
BECAME A LITTLE STEEPER OKAY
LET ME ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ON THE STREETS. I THINK WE
WOULD SHARE AN ECHO WETNESS
CORTEZ AND- RIGHT YOU SAD THAT
WE SAW THESE TRENDS START
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND WE'VE
SEEN AND CONTINUE ON THANK YOU.
THESE ARE POCKET SIZED THAT
TWELVE MONTH ELIGIBILITY
DEFINITELY PLAYED A ROLE BUT
WITHOUT A CLEAR PEOPLE HAVE
STEPPED OVER THE HARD FOR US TO
ACTUALLY SEE THE DIRECT CAUSE
EVENTS ALL WE CAN DO IS WORK
ACROSS SOME OF THE POLICIES
THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED. AND THAT
TWELVE MONTHS WOULD BE THE
LARGEST ONE- AND AT THE SAME
TIME WITH THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA FARMERS SERVICES IS
ALSO NOW. INITIATED THE TWELVE
MONTH FOR STAGE ONE SO WE MAY
BE SEEING MORE CHILDREN HELD IN
STAGE ONE BEFORE THEY MOVED TO
STAGE TWO ONE THREE. ALL OF
THOSE TRENDS OR SOMETHING. THAT
WILL. WATCH OVER ME. HERE'S TO
REALLY ON YOUR- THE INNER. OF
BUT POLICY AS WELL AS EXTERNAL
FACTORS LIKE. THEN LET ME GO TO
A GLOBAL QUESTION THAT MIGHT
RELATE TO THIS AND START WITH
THE L. A. O. IN RESPONSE. I
WONDER IF YOU HAD DATA ON THE
NUMBER AND TYPES OF PROVIDERS
THAT MAY HAVE CLOSED
PERMANENTLY OR TEMPORARILY
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND IT AND
REFLECTING ON THAT- HOW THAT
MADE HIM. IMPACT RE OPENING OF
THE STATE'S ECONOMY WHEN WE GET
TO IT HELLO. ERROR AND SO THERE
IS ACTUALLY SOME INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN YOUR AGENDA- ON
THIS EXACT QUESTION ON PAGE SIX
I'M SO ONE THING I'LL NOTE
ABOUT THIS DATA IS THAT THIS IS
THE ENTIRE WORLD. OUR LIFE OF
THE STATE'S LICENSE I'M CHILD
CARE PROVIDER IN THE STATE A
COUNTRY THAT APARTMENT A SOCIAL
SERVICES- SO WHAT THIS IS NOT
SHOWING YOU IS MORE SPECIFIC TO
THE SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY IN- IN IN STAGES
OKAY MORE SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
pTO. TWO OR THREE SO- THIS DATA
SHOWS CAN BECOME YOUR BREAK OUT
OF AS OF OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
WHO IS OPEN AND OPERATING WHO
IS TEMPORARY- HOW MANY-
FACILITIES AND KIND OF HOW THAT
EQUATES TO THE NUMBER OF SLOTS-
FOR TEMPORARY CLOSE. AND THEN
ALSO- IS PERMANENTLY CLOSED
SINCE MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
BUT IT THOSE NUMBERS DON'T
REFLECT ON THE ABILITY TO RE
OPEN TO HAVE ANY IDEA WHETHER
THAT'S JUST A- A COMPILATION OF
CLOSURE. IT IN ANY IDEA WHAT
WOULD BE READY. TO RE OPEN IF
WE MOVED TO THAT. YEAH THAT SO
A QUESTION I KNOW AND HAVE
ANSWERS THE WAY WE CAN GET SOME
OF THAT INFORMATION IS THROUGH
BY RELYING ON SOME OF THE
SURVEY DATA. SURVEY INFORMATION
THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS- AND THEN THE
SURVEYS HAVE REALLY BEEN.
TRYING TO GET OUT KIND OF WHAT
ARE THE BARRIERS AND WHAT ARE
THE ISSUES THAT- CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN FACING. IS
THAT SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
THEY THE SURVEY FINDINGS
HARVARD HAVE SHOWN IS THAT.
CHILD CARE PROVIDER FACING
HIGHER COSTS FROM CLEAN
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO SERVING- FEWER
CHILDREN AND SO THERE WERE THE
RECEIVING INCOME FROM FROM
CERTAIN FEWER CHILDREN. LET ME
ASK IF THE DEPARTMENT. OF
EDUCATION HAS ANY COMMENT ON
THAT. AT ONCE AGAIN I THINK WE
WOULD ECHO. WHAT IT. HAS IT'S
JUST SAD IN ADDITION MAKING. AS
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE COMPANY
ENVIRONMENT WE KNOW. DOT IN THE
SERVING LESS CHILDREN THAT HAS
OBVIOUSLY IMPACTED PROVIDERS AS
WELL. WRITERS REASONABLE ABLE
TO HOME THIS YEAR AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THEY REQUESTED FOR
NEXT YEAR AS WELL USER THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESSIBILITY BUT
WITH SERVING LESS CHILDREN AND-
SMALLER GROUPS FROM THIS IT
MEANS YOU'RE BRINGING LOS
RUNNING INTO THE PROGRAM WE
ALSO HAVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
JUST. RIGHT FOR SOME OF THE
CHILDREN ARE COMING IN PERSON
WHAT ARE ALSO SERVING MOM
AREN'T REMOTELY AND SET THAT IS
ADDING ADDITIONAL COSTS. SO
WELL WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY.
THAT IS CLOSE WITH RETURN AND
COME BACK OPEN. ARMS THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK THE CRIME IS
THE RIGHT NOW AS LOOK TO
STABILIZE CARE TO ENSURE. AND
STUFF ABOUT EARLY LEARNING HE-
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING OUT SOMEONE ACCESS
POINT IN YOU JUST RAISE THE NOT
KNOW. I THINK IT WAS A TO COME
UP LATER BUT- OF THE FACT THAT
THEIR NATIONAL COSTS DUE TO
SOME OF THE THINGS THE PANDEMIC
HOW ARE THEY BEING COVERED IN
TERMS OF SORT OF THE STATE
BUDGET. DOES THAT MEAN THAT THE
CHILD CARE CENTERS ET
ADDITIONAL COST. DEVELOPED
STATE SATURDAY FIFTH DAM
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO. I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY WOULD TELL US THAT
THEY WOULD COVER THEM BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE PUT OUT THE BUDGET
ADDITIONAL SIGNS TO ADDRESS
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AS WELL AS CLEAN. HI AND THEN
THEY CAN ALSO IF THEY HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH FAST CHARGE THEM
AS ELEMENTS. WE ALSO HELD HER
ONCE BOTH THAT THE VOUCHER SITE
ARM AS WELL AS CONTRACT INSTEAD
THAT THAT DECREASE IN REVENUE
WITH FAMILIES MORNING TECH
ATTENDING WE WERE SHELTERING IN
PLACE OR IF THEY HAD TO CLOSE
IN THE CLASSROOM OR THE WHOLE
PROGRAM TO THE COOKING
EXPOSURE. OR BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- REQUIRED THEM TO
CLOSE THAT THEIR CONTRACT. HELP
TURN THE CITY COULD STILL PAY
STAFF AND THEIR BRAND THOSE BIG
COST. FEATURES OF OPERATING.
THE END MAYBE TO. THAT THE- IS
HELL HARM MEANING THAT THEY
SERVED A HIGHER NUMBER OF
PEOPLE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
THEIR CONTRACTORS STILL HELD IN
PLACE EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE
SERVING LESS PEOPLE TO COVER
THE COSTS THAT MIGHT COME. FROM
THE PANDEMICS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. OKAY THANK YOU I WAS
GONNA ASK- THE QUESTIONS FROM
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU AFTER LEARNING-
THE TEN AGAIN PRECIADO
PRESENTATION I DID ONE DELVIN-
TO FOLLOW UP WITH- THE CHAIRS
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE NUMBERS
HERE FOR STAGE ONE TWO AND
THREE. AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND- IN YOUR
PRESENTATIONS- BUT I GUESS YOU
DON'T WANT YOUR EXPLANATIONS
AND I HAVE SEEN THAT- WITH
TWELVE MONTHS ELIGIBILITY YEAH
YOU HAVE MORE PEOPLE STAYING
STAGE ONE VERSUS PROGRESS IN
STAGE TWO BUT I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT THE- THIS. IS TRULY
MAINLY DISPLACEMENT WE WOULD
SEE A LARGE INCREASE THE STAGE
ONE COMMENSURATE WITH THE
DECREASE IN STAGE TWO. SO BUT
WE DON'T SEE THAT SO SOMETHING
ELSE IS GOING ON- BECAUSE WE
HAVE A TWO POINT FOUR ENTRIES.
IN STAGE ONE FOR PROJECTED BUT
THEN AT EIGHTEEN POINT 5%
DECREASE AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL RAW NUMBERS YOU CAN SEE
ALSO THAT THE- THE ACTUAL RUN
NUMBERS- THERE'S A BIG CHANGE
HERE TOO. RIGHT SO EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN UP VERSUS
TEN THOUSAND DOWN. SO- SO
PERHAPS CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT
AND ALSO I GUESS THE OTHER
THING IS HE DIED IN SUB THREE
WE ALSO- HAD A PRESENTATION
EARLIER ON CAL WORKS. I GUESS
WHEN THE QUESTIONS WHEN THE
MYSTERIES I SHOULD SAY BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T REALLY GET A GOOD
EXPLANATION WAS THAT THERE WAS
A FALLEN CAL WORKS KNOWING THAT
STAGE ONE STAGE TWO ARE.
POTENTIALLY. ENTITLEMENTS FOR
PEOPLE ON CAL WORKS. HOW MUCH
OF THIS IS DUE TO- EIGHT EIGHT
PROJECTION THAT POWER DOESN'T
GOING TO INCREASE LIKE WE
THOUGHT IT WAS WITH THE
PANDEMIC BUT I GUESS THAT LAMB
I GUESS I'M CONCERNED THAT ONCE
PEOPLE RUN OUT THEIR EMPLOYMENT
SO FOURTH WE WEREN'T SURE THAT
CAO WORKS WASN'T GOING TO SIR
JUMPING UP. AND WHEN THAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN SO- AND PERHAPS
MAYBE BY MAY REVISE IT HAVE
BETTER NUMBERS- BUT I THINK.
THIS MAY ALSO BE PARTIALLY TIED
TO THIS MYSTERY ABOUT WHY CAO
WORKS HASN'T GONE UP AS MUCH IS
EXPECTED AND WE NEVER GOT A
REALLY GOOD ANSWER FOR THAT AND
I THINK PEOPLE ARE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE IT OUT. GEN SO CAN
THERE BE A KEY PLEASE COMMENT
ON. BOTH ALL OF THE
DISPLACEMENT ISSUE AS WELL AS-
HOW MUCH IS TO BE AFFECTED BY-
POTENTIAL CHANGES AND CAL WORKS
THAT WE MIGHT NOT BE
ANTICIPATING- IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. THERE'S A SERVER
NOW FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO I'LL JUST GO AHEAD
AND START AND SAY THAT I DO
THINK WE AGREE THAT THE
MYSTERIES THAT WE SEE ARE. ARE
VERY DIFFICULT TO TEASE OUT WE
DON'T HAVE EXACT DATA ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THE PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF THE
POLICY CHANGES THAT HAPPEN. AND
HOW THAT AFFECTS CASELOAD IN
COST PER CASE SO THAT'S
SOMETHING WE TRY TO TEASE OUT
EVERY YEAR- AND THAT'S WHY WE
WORK SO CLOSELY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR TO AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HAPPENING
AND SOMETIMES. WHAT WE SEE IN
THE DATA DOES NOT REFLECT WHAT
WE THINK WOULD HAPPEN AND SO WE
JUST MAKE OUR BEST ESTIMATES
BASED OFF THAT- AND YOU ARE
CORRECT IN MAY REVISION WE WILL
HAVE UPDATED CASELOAD NUMBERS
AN UPDATED COST PER CASE
NUMBERS AS WELL. SO WE'LL HAVE
A LITTLE BIT ABOVE MORE REFINED
ESTIMATE THEN- AND YEAH SO I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THOSE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT WE AGREE ARE
ALSO MYSTERIES THAT WE TRY TO
FIGURE OUT AND WE DON'T HAVE.
GREAT NUMBERS ARE. PARTICULARLY
CONSIDERING THAT THE
INTERACTION EFFECT OF A LOT OF
THESE TWO IS REALLY. DIFFICULT
FOR US TO PART. SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT AND
WHAT MORE UPDATED NUMBERS IN
ME. AND I GUESS THE FOLLOW UP
IS IF WE HAVE GUESSED WRONG BY
MAY- AND WHEN WE WILL HAVE
UPDATED NUMBERS IN MAY AND THEN
TO THE EXTENT THAT CURRENT YOUR
NUMBERS LOOK A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT AS WELL WE TRY TO
REMAIN AS RESPONSIVE AS
POSSIBLE- TO ANNIE BUDGET
REVISIONS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN
FOR THESE PROGRAMS. OKAY ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM. OTHER
FOLKS. SURE I CAN'T COMMENT ON
THE SERLIO. R. ONE THING I DID
WANT TO MENTION IS THAT IN OUR
WOULDN'T LEAD YOU INDEPENDENT
ESTIMATES OF COLOR CHILD CARE
AND FOR STAGE ONE THIS IS YOUR
KIND OF HERE REACHED ON AT THE
HEART OF THE ISSUE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE CONSIDER IS THE
OVER ALL KIND OF WORKS
AGREEMENT INTO OUR- STAGE ONE
INTERSTAGE ONE ESTIMATES THAT
ARE STAGE ONE ESTIMATES REALLY
DO FEED INTO OUR STAGE AND
STAGE TWO AND STAGE THREE
ESTIMATE SO. THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL CONSIDER WHEN WE
WHEN WE CAN DOCTOR INDEPENDENT
ESTIMATES AND WE COMPARE THOSE
TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S I'M AS
AS WE CONTINUE ALONG THIS
BUDGET PROCESS OKAY SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL AS BY MAY IS MAYBE SOME
SPARKLE SENSITIVITY ANALYSES I
KNOW YOU DO YOUR BEST GUESS BUT
SERVE A RANGE OF THINGS THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN. GIVEN WHAT YOU
KNOW WEEDS SENSOR STILL BIT OF
A MYSTERY ON CAL WORKS OF
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN ACCOUNT
WORK SO HOPEFULLY SOMEONE'S
DELVING INTO UNEMPLOYMENT DATA
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS. AND
LOOKING AT SAYING OKAY WELL
THIS IS A RANGE OF THINGS THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN- AND- SO WE CAN IN
THE- PERHAPS BETTER ANTICIPATE
WHERE YOU KNOW EACH TIME YOU
TEND TO GIVE US IN A NUMBER BUT
THE QUESTION IS HOW GOOD IS
THAT NUMBER WHAT'S THE RANGE OF
PROBABILITY WERE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT HOW WIDE IS IT IS A
FAIRLY NARROW IS A FAIRLY WIDE-
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE HERE IS. THE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAM IS ALSO
PROJECTED TO DROP BY NINETEEN
POINT EIGHT PERCENT- I NOTE
THAT TO NINETEEN TWENTY WITH
FIFTY FOUR WOULD JUMP UP TO
SEVENTY EIGHT DOWN THE SIXTY
THREE- CAN YOU CAN THERE BE AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY THAT
PROJECTION WHEN THE NUMBERS
GOING UP AND THEN SUDDENLY
GOING NOW. PROTECTING IT'S
GONNA SUDDENLY. DROP HELLO
AGAIN- SO IN ORDER TO. OF SO.
ON TO BE CLEAR AND ARE NOT. ON
THAT WE PUT OUT FOR THE
ALTERNATE PAYMENT. GROUND AND-
IN THE CURRENT YEAR IN THE
BUDGET AFTER TWENTY TWENTY WE
HAVE SHOWN THAT THERE WAS A BIG
INCREASE IN. THE NUMBER OF
VOUCHERS ARE AVAILABLE FOR. FOR
EMERGENCY VOUCHERS FOR
ESSENTIAL FAMILIES. AND SO
THOSE VOUCHERS ARE ONE TIME IN
NATURE AND THERE'S OVER. A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF VOUCHERS THAT ARE REFLECTED
IN OUR CASE LOW NUMBERS FOR
THAT PROGRAM- IN THE- TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET YEAR- AND SO.
WHEN WE TOOK THOSE OUT FOR OUR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO NUMBERS
ON THE NECESSARILY LOOK LIKE
THE SLOTS OF GONE GONE DOWN
BUT- THE OVERALL NUMBER OF
ONGOING SLOTS REMAINS THE SAME
IT IS IN FACT A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER WITH THE NEW PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR FUNDS THAT ARE
FUNDING. A NEW ALTERNATE
PAYMENTS LAW. IT IS THOSE-
SHORT TERM ONE TIME EMERGENCY
VOUCHERS LOTS ARE NO LONGER
BEING REFLECTED. OKAY SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT BY JULY FIRST- WILL
BE IN A SITUATION WHERE YOU
MIGHT NOT NEED TO I REALIZE
THAT THE TECHNICALLY THEY ARE
ONLY IF. YOU KNOW TEMPORARY BUT
THAT WE WILL NEED TO SELL AND-
OR DO SOMETHING FOR THE FOLKS
WHOSE- VOUCHERS ARE EXPIRING
THE CENTRAL WORKERS. THAT THE
SITUATION WILL BE SUCH THAT
THEY WILL NO LONGER NEED THEM
OR THAT. WILL MAKE A CONSCIOUS
DECISION TO. EVEN IF. THEY JUST
DO NEED THEM THAT WE WILL BAN
THEM. I THINK EVEN NOW WE'RE
SEEING THAT WITH SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
WE HAVE THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
ADDRESS ON THIS EXACT QUESTION
OF. HOW TO EXTEND THE VOUCHERS
AND TO BE RESPONSIVE TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE FIELD IN TERMS
OF WHAT FAMILIES NEED AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
PANDEMIC- I KNOW WE'LL TOUCH ON
WHAT'S GOING ON THE FEDERAL
FUNDS A LITTLE BIT LATER BUT-
ALL THAT TO SAY THAT SOME OF
THE FUND. THE FUNDS WE'RE
CONTINUING TO GET FROM THE FEDS
INCLUDES. DOLLARS TO EXTEND
THOSE SLOTS AND I NEW SLOTS AS
WELL SO THAT NUMBER WILL BE
UPDATED. CONTINUOUSLY OKAY AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT THESE. ARE
GENERATED- PRE THE SECOND
STIMULUS TO CORRECT. RIGHT OKAY
SO HOPEFULLY MAY REVISE WILL
HAVE A BETTER REFLECTION WHAT
THE BOTH THE FEDERAL FUNDING IS
AS WELL AS STATE. FOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IF
I CAN GO BACK A LITTLE BIT
HEALTHWORKS PART AND THAT DATA
WE JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT OUR CURRENT DATA
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO STAGE
TEAM ESTIMATES INDICATE THAT
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDS TO COVER THE CURRENT
ROMANCE BUT THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT FUNDS BURKE WROTE WE
ARE ANTICIPATING SOME GIRLS.
THREE FUNDS INCLUDING MARKET ON
X. FACTOR SUCH AS A RISE IN
ELIGIBILITY. AS WE BRING MANY
MORE FAMILIES LOSING THEIR
INCOME AND BEING BECOMING
ELIGIBLE FOR OUR- PROGRAM
FACTORS SUCH AS TRANSFERS FROM
EACH ONE. WE CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT STAGE ONE ESTIMATES THAT
WOULD BE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
WORSE WE WOULD ANTICIPATE SOME
GROWTH IN. H. U. N. HAVE
ANTICIPATED. IN THE ESTIMATES
THAT WE- THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW
I'M IN THE MOST CENTER MCKAY
SAYS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN MY
AND MY QUESTIONS I THINK ARE
SIMILAR. TO WHAT HAS BEEN ASKED
ABOUT BUT THE ONE QUESTION I DO
I JUST HAVE ON- CHILD CARE
LICENSE THAT THE CLOSURES. THE
ALL THOSE SLOTS THAT ARE
CORRESPONDING WITH THE
FACILITIES. THOSE ARE STILL
BALLOTS LOTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
WITHOUT ANY PLACE TO GO
CURRENTLY. SORRY YOU BROKE UP
JUST A SECOND YOU'RE ASKING THE
QUESTION SO YOU. SO THE
PERMANENTLY CLOSE SLOT SINCE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AND ALL OF
THE- THE FACILITIES THAT ARE
CLOSE WITH THE CORRESPONDING
SLOTS THOSE ARE STILL OUT THERE
SOMEWHERE WHERE ARE THOSE.
WHERE ARE THOSE CHILDREN. I'M
SO SORRY ACTUALLY- I'M SURE
WHERE THEIR CHILDREN ARE BEING
SERVED AT THIS POINT- SOME OF
THESE WERE THESE WERE ASK CHILD
CARE FACILITIES THAT WERE
LICENSED PRE PANDEMIC AND THOSE
FACILITIES HAVE DECIDED TO
COULD NOT- NOT CONTINUE ON- AS-
AS OF OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
THAT THEY WOULD BE PERMANENTLY
CLOSED. OKAY WHICH I GUESS IS
THAT THE I THINK THE ISSUE A
LOT OF US ARE RAISING A THERE'S
A LOT OF KIDS OUT THERE THAT WE
ALL NEED OUR ARE DESPERATELY IN
NEED OFCARE AND ARE WE- NOT
JUST COUNTING NUMBERS BY
ANTICIPATING. WHERE THEY ARE
AND WHEN THEY COME IN HOW DO WE
HELP THEM COMMAND AND WHEN THEY
DO COME IN HOW DO WE BEST. THAT
TREAT THEM- IN IN IN REGARDS TO
THE PREVIUS- HEARING WE HAVE A
WE ASK OUR EXPERTS YOU KNOW.
WHY DO YOU SEE PARTY THANK YOU
SEE THIS AND I ASKED ABOUT. ARE
THERE TRENDS NATIONWIDE THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT TO HELP US MAKE
SOME PREDICTIONS IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY. SO FROM SOCIAL
SERVICE PERSPECTIVE BUT THEN
ALSO I THINK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. ARE WE
SEEING SOME OF THESE SAME
TRENDS. ON THE CHILD CARE
ISSUE. ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
WHEN WE HOPEFULLY COME OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC WHICH WILL BE.
ACTING CORRESPONDING WITH. WITH
SCHOOL STARTING AGAIN WILL BE
PREPARED. FOR THE AMOUNT OF
HOPEFULLY BECAUSE WE KNOW. THE
MAJORITY PEOPLE HAVE TO DROP%
OUT OF THE WORKFORCE OUR. WOMEN
OF COLOR CARING FOR KIDS. ONE
WE'RE READY FOR THEM TO GO BACK
WILL BE READY FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND WE HAVE ENOUGH
SLOTS OPEN TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
THEM EFFECTIVELY. WHO WAS THAT
DIRECTED TO THE PART OF
EDUCATION. I THINK WE'RE ALL
TRACKING WHAT'S HAPPENING
ACROSS THE NATION YEAH YOU'RE
RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA RISKY EVERYWHERE AND
MAKING THIS YEAR EARLIER NO ONE
REALLY KNOWS WHAT TO EXPECT.
LINA KHAN IS FOR WE ACTUALLY
SEE MORE FAMILY CHILD
BUSINESSES OPEN UP AND WHEN THE
ECONOMY IS WRITING AND YOU'RE
REALLY WELL. ACTION AND NOT
BECAUSE THEY CAN GO TO OTHER
BUSINESS TYPES AND MAKE WORK
FUN. RIGHT NOW KNOWINGLY AS WE
WALKED FIFTEEN EXTRA CARE AS
WELL AS THE NEXT CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS. AND MEANING TO
SUPPORT DEVELOPMENTS AS CARE
PROGRAMS MOVING FORWARD IS
SOMETHING INTERESTING
DEFINITELY NOT A GOOD IN THE
MASTER PLAN SO THINGS LIKE.
SHARED SERVICE NETWORKS THAT
CAN REALLY HELP STABILIZE AND
BUILD CAPACITY THAT SOMETHING.
GIRLS NEED TO DO MORE CELLS
CAPACITY. I THINK THAT'S JUST
THAT'S SOMETHING ALONG THE TO
WORK TOGETHER ON ASKING EXPERT
OUT BOTH IN THE RESOURCE SECTOR
AS WELL AS IN THE CHILD CARE
SECTOR. THANK YOU TO ME ARE OR
ANY OF THE CHILD CARE CENTERS
DOING ANY LEVEL OF- ONLINE
HYBRID. I KNOW FOR THAT
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION OUR DIRECT
CONTRACTED PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE INFANTILE LEARN HERE AS
WELL AS SCHOOL AGE CARE.
PROGRAM AND ALL OF THEM ARE. IT
COST THEY ALL HAVE SOME
PROBLEMS DOING THAT HYBRID
MODELS MAINLY BECAUSE THEIR
CAPACITY REDUCE REDUCE MICHAEL
AND THEY WERE THEY CAN ONLY SEE
IN PERSON LAST. THEY WITHOUT
REDUCE. SO LET'S SAY THEY COULD
HAVE TWENTY FOUR CHILDREN OUR
CLASSROOMS AND NOW CAN ONLY
HAVE TWELVE TO MEET THE CURRENT
STANDARDS THEY THAT ARE SERVING
THE OTHER CHILDREN. A DISTANCE
LEARNING MODEL AND THEN YOU
ALSO HAVE SOME PROGRAMS THAT
ARE FULLY CLOSE TO BEING IN
PERSON BASED ON THAT THERE
MIGHT BE A SCHOOL CAMPUS WILL
SCHOOL CAMPUSES CLOSE. MONDAY
MAY HAVE HAD ENOUGH. OKAY THAT
COMMUNITY WHERE HE I'M PUBLIC
HEALTH FEEL SAFE HOW CONSERVE.
SUPER OF. AS TO REASONS WORKING
KNOWLEDGE. IN PERSON HI BRAD AS
WELL AS JUST. THANK YOU AND
BECAUSE WE KNOW IN OUR LARGER
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATION CENTERS
THERE THEY HAVE GIVEN OUT HOT
SPOTS AND DEVICES HAVE WE DONE
THIS HAVE WE PROVIDED FOR THE
SAME IN OUR CHILD CARE. CENTERS
TO HELP THEM WITH TECHNOLOGY.
YES THAT SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE PURCHASED THE QUICKNESS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT SOME OF OUR
QUALITY PROJECTS THAT ARE
FUNDED THROUGH THE CHILD CARE
AND DEVELOPMENT FUNDS. I WAS
ALSO SUPPORTED. BY FORCE SHE
BETTER HELP CONNECTIVITY'S.
FROM AND THERE'S A VARIETY OF
THINGS YOU CAN IMAGINE CIRCLE
TIME REMOTELY AND HAVING
CHILDREN CHECK IN EVERY DAY. SO
THAT THEY KEEP UP THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL. AND SPEND ONE OF THE
THINGS. COGNISANT NOT HOW WAS
THE FORCE AND WHEN WE KNOW
THERE MIGHT BE MUCH MORE THERE
CAN AND JUSTICE OF THAT SO
HAPPY NOT ONGOING. ALL OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I GUESS
IT WOULD WE ALL THE COME BACK
TO THE POINT THE WE REALLY NEED
TO HAVE A GOOD DAY AND- TO MAKE
THE GOOD TO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MAN YEAH I WANTED TO
FOLLOW ON A LESS COMMENT- ABOUT
DATE I MEAN WE THERE'S COULD A
FAN HERE THAT IS ON EXPLAINED
THAT THAT IS CONCERNING TO US
ALL AND I GUESS I'D BE
INTERESTED- YOU KNOW WHEN I
THINK OF WHEN YOU HAVE A
PHENOMENON IN OTHER CONTEXTS
YOU TYPICALLY YOU KNOW FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOUR HYPOTHESES ARE
YOU TRYING TO TEST THOSE WITH
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EMPIRICAL
DATA. OUT ONE OF THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THE COMING MONTHS TO TRY TO
PIN DOWN WHAT THE EXACT ISSUES
HERE ARE WHAT WHAT'S DRIVING
THIS PHENOMENON OF A REDUCTION
IN STAGE TWO CHILD CARE- SO L.
A. L. LET ME LET ME START WITH
YOU LIKE WHAT DO YOU THINK WE
COULD THE ADMINISTRATION CAN DO
IN THE COMING MONTHS. I TO TRY
TO TEST THIS IN AND TENNIS DOWN.
I'M NOT SURE ACTUALLY I HAVE A
GOOD ANSWER FOR- FOR YOU BEYOND
KIND OF THE THINGS THAT I'M I'M
OBSERVING THE ADMINISTRATION
DOING WHICH IS- DEVELOPING.
DIFFERENT DEVELOPING THESE
ESTIMATES AND- YOU KNOW
BRIEFING US ON THESE ESTIMATES
THAT WE CAN- KIND OF TEST IN A
SUIT AND- CHECK AND SEE THAT
THESE ASSUMPTIONS ARE
REASONABLE- BUT- BUT YEAH IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE YEAR WE'RE
AWARE OF AND WE'RE- CONSTANTLY
LOOKING INTO AND MONITORING AND
OF WHAT. A WHAT THE CASE
LOOKING THE CURRENT CASE IT IS
LOOKING LIKE SO WE CAN. MAKE
ESTIMATES OF INTO THE FUTURE
BURKE FOR BUDGET YAR ESTIMATES
ARE ONE OF THOSE APPROPRIATE
BUY ANOTHER CONTEXT YOU MIGHT
LOOK AT. BOTH QUANTITATIVE DATA
AND QUALITATIVE DATA YOU MIGHT
LOOK TO INTERVIEW PEOPLE. AND
SEE WHAT YOU KNOW. WHY SOMEONE
PERHAPS DROPPED OUT AT STAGE
TWO AND DIDN'T ENROLL. YOU IN
OUR THEIR PLANS UNDER WAY TO.
THINK THROUGH THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS LIKE A REALLY. BIG DEAL
RIGHT AND SO I GUESS. YEP YOU
WATER BUT MAYBE THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND EDUCATION- DO YOU
WHAT DO YOU GUYS PLANNING TO
DO. TO TRY TO YOU KNOW BECAUSE
OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
LARGE NUMBERS BUT THOSE ONLY
GIVE YOU A PARTIAL PICTURE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON- WATER YEAR
SORT OF. OTHER STEPS HERE THAT
YOU THINKING ABOUT GOING. TO
TRY TO. YOU KNOW IDENTIFY THE-
OF. AND. WELL I CAN SPEAK OUT
BRIEFLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE DON'T WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR TO GET
ADDED SOME ADDITIONAL DATA
COLLECTION FROM OUR STAGES AND
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROVIDERS.
AND THAT DATA HAS HELPED US
UNDERSTAND SOME EMPTY BOXES AND
BASICALLY ESTIMATES AROUND
PAYMENTS WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
MONEY IS FLOWING ONE TIME
MONEY. TO OUR- AND- BUT I WILL
SAY WE HAVE A PANDEMIC WE ALSO
HAVE THAT TRANSITION OF ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS OVER TO SOCIAL
SERVICES SO THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE HANDING THAT OFTEN HANDING
OFF THAT NEED TO TRACK IT ONE
THING THAT YOU'VE PROBABLY
HEARD LIKE THREE IN THE PAST IS
THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE
STRONGEST STATE ASSISTANCE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THE SENATE TRYING THE
WAY WE HAVE ISSUED QUITE A FEW
DIFFERENT SURGERIES
SPECIFICALLY DESTINY THINGS
LIKE STATE THEM THE PROVIDERS
AND CONTRACTORS TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN GET THOSE OUT BUT I WILL
SAY THERE IS A LOT OF FATIGUE
SO THEY ALSO HAVE SURVEYED
FIFTY GETS PART OF THAT I HAVE
BEEN WORKING HARDER THAN EVER
THIS YEAR TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE STILL. OPERATING AND-
DEMONSTRATE MADE IT THAT MUCH
HARDER. AND THEN YOU ADD ON
THAT. NEEDING MORE. FROM NOW
AND- I WILL SAY THEY HAVE DONE
QUITE A- AND- ACTORS. TO ALL OF
OUR PROGRAMS. YEAH THANK YOU.
SENATE BOOK. YOUR MARK. GOOD
MORNING. SO I HAVE A QUESTION
WITH REGARD TO THE VOUCHERS AND
I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS
DIRECTED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUT I'M JUST GOING TO
READ REALLY QUICKLY HERE SENATE
STATES THAT THE THREE STAGES OF
CAL WORKS CHILD CARE AND YOU'LL
TURN INTO PAYMENT PROGRAM ARE
REIMBURSED THROUGH VOUCHERS AND
THAT THE STATE WILL ONLY PAY UP
TO THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE.
WHICH AS OF RIGHT NOW IS BASED.
SEE THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE IS
CURRENTLY SET AT SEVENTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN. RMR SURVEY SURVEY.
HOW OFTEN IS THE ORIGINAL
REGIONAL MARKET RATE ARE WE
EVALUATED AND WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR UPDATING THIS AMOUNT IT
SEEMS TO BE SEVERELY
UNDERFUNDED. HI SIR BERNARD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE- THE
SURVEY IS CONDUCTED EVERY TWO
YEARS- TO CAPTURE THE MOST
RECENT INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
MUCH CHID CARE COSTS IN THE
FIELD- AND- THERE THERE'S NO
STATUTE THAT DOESN'T THERE'S AN
INTENT BUT SAYS THAT WE WILL
UPDATE TO THE MOST CURRENT RATE
AND- WE CURRENTLY ARE NOT AT
THE MOST RECENT SURVEY RATE- AT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN- BUT-
STILL IT'S NOT THAT WE HAVE
MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RATES-
THROUGH. THIS BODY TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WITH OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE UNION
WILL WILL BE RESPONSIVE TO
THOSE BUT AT THIS POINT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS ARE
NOT PROPOSING ANYTHING
DIFFERENT AT THIS TIME. OKAY SO
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY YOU
SAID IT SHOULD BE REEVALUATED
EVERY TWO YEARS BUT IT HAS NOT.
IS THAT CORRECT. THERE'S AN
INTENT TO DO SO ON THE LANGUAGE
AT THE VERY LEAST- BUT THERE'S
NOTHING THAT SAYS THAT- IN
MINISTRATION TO UPDATE IT ON TO
THE TO THE MOST CURRENT ONE- SO.
IT IS NOT AT THE MOST UPDATED-
ARMOR SURVEY THAT THERE
CURRENTLY IS RIGHT NOW. IN A
NEW SURVEY IS BEING CONDUCTED
AS WELL IT'S A LITTLE PUSHED
OUT BECAUSE OF CO IN NINETEEN-
BUT AT THIS TIME WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING ANY CHANGES TO THE
RATES. SO JUST TO FOLLOW UP
QUICKLY THERE'S AN INTENT TO DO
IT BUT IT HASN'T BEEN DONE IS
THAT BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. YES BUT THAT'S WHAT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE MARKET. THANK
YOU WHY IS THAT I'M JUST KIND
OF CURIOUS I GENERAL TROUBLE
YES. NON RECOGNIZING YOU TO ASK
A QUESTION REYES ALL. HER
QUESTION WAS WHY IS THAT. THANK
YOU FOR CLARIFYING SO WE DO PAY
ATTENTION VERY CLOSELY UNTIL
YOU KNOW THE STRUGGLE THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN THE CHILD CARE
FIELD AND IN TERMS OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE ON THERE BUT
A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
ALIGNING THE RAIDS ABOUT MAKING
A MORE EQUITABLE I BELIEVE THE
MOST RECENT CHANGES THAT WE
MADE HAD TO DO WITH ADJUSTMENT
FACTORS FOR. INFANTS AND
TODDLERS WHICH WE HEARD FROM
THE FIELD HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL- AND LOCAL THE NINETEEN
HAPPENED LAST YEAR TOO THERE IS
EVEN MORE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO DO IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW BEING THERE FOR THE CHILD
CARE FIELD- AND PROTECTING YOU
KNOW OUR FISCAL PICTURE AS WELL
SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT A LOT OF
THESE CHANGES ARE HAPPENING THE
FIELD WAS CALLED THE NINETEEN
WITH THE TRANSITION WITH
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT THE
QUESTION OF THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT RACE. I'M SURE WILL COME
UP AGAIN IT'S MENTIONED A
LITTLE BIT IN THE MASTER PLAN
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE MORE CONVERSATIONS IN THE
FUTURE WILL CERTAINLY- YOU
MEMBER OF THOSE AS WELL BUT IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING ANY CHANGES AT THIS
TIME. SO MOVING FORWARD WHAT
WOULD BE THE BEST COURSE OF
ACTION TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THESE. FEES UPDATED. SO THAT WE
COULD SEE MORE EQUITY AND MORE-
CONSTANT RELIABILITY IN THE
FUNDING. SANTA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TESTS YOU BUILDUP LET
pTHE TWENTY SIXTEEN RIGHT NOW
BUT WE DO HAVE TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REGARDING OUR- BUT
WHAT ABOUT OUR TWENTY TWENTY
SURVEY HAS BEEN PUSHED OUT DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC AND SO MANY OF.
THE PROGRAMS CLOSE. OPENCLOSE
WE HAVE ASKED X. OF THAT
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL. AND ARE
HOPING THAT THEY GRANT THAT
EXTENSION WHICH MEANS WE WOULD
THEN HAVE. A NEW MARKET RATE
FOR. ONE FULL. MEMBERS RATE THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST. DID IT
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY PARKING
THE TODDLER CARE I'M NOT HAS
HELPED STABILIZE THAT END OF
THE SPECTRUM THE PRESCHOOL
RIGHT HAS NOT BEEN ADDRESSED.
YEARS SO I MENTIONED THAT
EARLIER IN MY TALKING POINTS IS
THAT ACTUALLY LOWER THAN THEIR
REGIONAL MARKETING FOR EXEMPTS
CARE PROGRAM SO WHEN YOU THINK
OF. THE HIGH QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA. LOWER AND
MANY. OF LICENSE FROM. THERE'S
A LOT OF INEQUITIES AS LOOK
ACROSS THE FIELD IN RIGHT. SO
HOW SOON CAN WE SEE IF WE WERE
TO MOVE FORWARD MAKING SURE
ASSURING THAT WE HAD THIS
INCREASED. TO HAVE THE MOST
UPDATED AMOUNT STE OF THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATES. HOW SOON
COULD WE SEE THAT IN EFFECT HOW
LONG. DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
S. SETTING OF RATES IS NOT
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS TO PROVIDE A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN JOB MARKET RATE
OKAY BUT THAT WOULD REALLY BE
ANYA AND- I JUST PICTURE WERE-
I'M ACTUALLY ADDRESSING HIGH
WHAT'S OURS. I THINK- TROUBLE
STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT WHEN
THIS ACTUALLY GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S
WHAT'S BEING INTERESTED IN THE
ANSWER AND I DON'T KNOW IF ANY
OF THE THREE OF YOU. CAN
ADDRESS HER QUESTION OF MINE
THIS WILL ACTUALLY HAPPEN. I
CAN SPEAK TO THAT SERVER TYPES
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'M SO TYPICALLY WAY AND- THERE
HAVE BEEN RATE INCREASES OF TO
HAPPEN THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS I'M SURE THE LAST TIME
THERE. REGIONAL MARKET RATE
WAS- WAS INCREASED- THAT WAS
DONE- THROUGH THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT. THAT WAS PASSED AT
THE END OF JUNE HAS ACTIVE JULY
ONE BUT THE ACTUAL RATE CHANGE
WASN'T IMPLEMENTED UNTIL-
JANUARY MID YEAR WHICH GAVE THE
IMMINENT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ABOUT A SIX MONTH
PERIOD TO- TO. IMPLEMENT KIND
OF THE CHANGES THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RATE AND
HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION A LITTLE BIT BUT I'M
HAPPY TO FOLLOW. WITH ME FOR
ONE BECAUSE AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS.
BECAUSE PART OF HER QUESTION
WAS WHETHER OR NOT IT REQUIRED
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO DO. IT SO
HEY YOU JUST SAID HOW IT MIGHT
BE DONE. IS THERE ENOUGH. FORTY
TO DO THAT WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION. SO IT WOULD REQUIRE A
STATUS CHANGE YES. KILEY ACTION.
TO WOULD RE. LED ACTION. AND
LET ME GLEAN. FROM CENTER GROVE
BOUGHT CHAU BOOKS QUESTION YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US DISCUSS
THAT AT SOME POINT WHEN WE GET
DOWN TO DECISION MAKING YES I
JUST THINK THE IT BUT THE RATES
ARE. EXTREMELY UNDERFUNDED AND
I THINK IT BE FAIR. FOR THE
WELL BEING OF OUR KIDS AND
EVERYBODY THAT'S INVOLVED. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE UP TO
DATE ON THAT AND SO YES
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU TO SIX
COMPLETE REQUEST YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- THAT COMPLETES
ISSUES. I'M SORRY- CENTER
EGGMAN SAID. JUST TO MAKE A
BRIEF STATEMENT ON RATES AT ABU
YOU'LL FIND AT THE OTHER END OF
THE SPECTRUM- IN CARING FOR
MOST SENIOR WE HAVE SOME OF THE
SAME ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. NOTHING SEPARATE FROM
ANYTHING ELSE THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THAT POINT. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO BUT
BEFORE WE DO I'M GONNA MAKE ONE
CORRECTION FOR THOSE OF YOU
FOLLOWING AT HOME- THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER I GAVE FOR
THOSE OF YOU PLANNING TO USE IT
AFTER ISSUE FOR WAS NOT EXACTLY
CORRECT SILVA CORRECT. DIAL IN
NUMBER. IS. 844-291-6358 THE
ACCESS CODE IS THE SAME I'LL
REPEAT THEM BOTH BEFORE WE GO
TO QUESTIONS AFTER ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. MORE MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS IN
CHILD CARE NEEDS. IT IS OUR
SAME PANELISTS AS WE JUST HEARD
BUT IT'S A DIFFERENT ORDER OF
THIS TIME SO WE'LL START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GO
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND THEN GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO WILL
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN THIS IS
SERRA PARTNER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO I'M
GOING TO GO OVER. A VERY BRIEF
HISTORY OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WE HAVE- THAT THE STATE
HAS RECEIVED TO DATE. ARE AND
WHAT WE'VE DONE FOR THE CHILD
CARE FEEL WHAT THOSE FUNDS AND
THEN I'LL GO TO A LITTLE BIT OF
DISCUSSION ON THE BRAND NEW
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE HAVEN'T.
AND THIS IS A REALLY A RECENT
PROCESS AS LATE AS LAST WEEK.
NOW SOME OF THESE. DOCUMENTS
WERE RELEASED IN TERMS OF WHAT.
IS IN STORE FOR THE NEWTON WAS
FEDERAL FUNDS SO I'LL GO AHEAD
AND START WITH WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY- CALIFORNIA RECEIVED A
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY POINT THREE
MILLION FOR THE FEDERAL CARE.
ACT FOR CALLED THE NINETEEN
RELATED CHILDCARE ACTIVITIES-
SO WITH THAT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION A HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION. WAS
USED FOR STATE COSTS
ASSOCIATED. WITH VAROUS-
EXPENDITURES FROM LAST YEAR
INCLUDING FAMILY FEE WAIVERS-
PROVIDER PAYMENT PROTECTIONS-
YOU ABOUT YOUR THOUGHTS. AND
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
I'M A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WAS USE FOR- STIPENDS.
UNDER TWENTY FIVE MILLION WAS
USE FOR SUPPORTING DATABASE
PROVIDERS UP TO SIXTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION. I WAS USED TO
FUND PROVIDERS ACCEPTING THE
DOCTORS AT THE MAXIMUM
CERTIFIED LEVEL OF NEED. AT
LEAST SIXTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION WAS FOR ONE TIME
STIPENDS. FOR PROVIDERS
ACCEPTING VOUCHERS THAT OFFER
CARE DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC- SIMILARLY IN
THE HOT SUN YOU THREE MILLION
WAS USED TO CONTINUE CARE FOR.
HIS CHILDREN AN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS IN EIGHT MILLION WAS
USED TO EXTEND FAMILY FEE
WAIVERS UNTIL JUNE THIRTY OF
TWENTY TWENTY- SO THAT WAS OUR
FIRST TRANCHE OF FEDERAL FUNDS.
IN OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY. IT
MINISTRATION PROVIDED AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED TEN MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS TO CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO REIMBURSE THEM FOR
THE COST. AWAY FAMILY FEES AND
TO EXTEND THE LENGTH OF CARE
FOR CHILDREN OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WITH TEMPORARY
TEMPORARY VOUCHERS ON
SPECIFICALLY THIRTY MILLION WAS
PROVIDED. FOR THE WAY FAMILY
FEES AND EMAILING WAS PROVIDED.
TO EXTEND ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
FOR CHILDREN. OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- INTO ADDRESS THE
INCREASED OF CARE. OFFICE AGED.
IN LATE DECEMBER PASSED THE
CREW RESPONSE RELEASE UP RELIEF
SOME APPROPRIATE ACTS THAT
INCLUDED APPROXIMATELY TEN
POINT THREE BILLION CHILD CARE
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT A CDBG
CODED RELIEF FUNDS FOR CHILD
CARE ON CALIFORNIA RECEIVED
NINE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR MILLION
OF THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS. ALSO
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
EARLY ACTION LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
FIELD RIGHT NOW- THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL OF THAT
NIGHT HER SIXTY FOUR MILLION.
WILL BE FUNDED WITH FOUR
HUNDRED TWO MILLION FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE RELEASED
SUPPLEMENTAL ACT FUNDS- WE'RE
PROPOSING TWO HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR MILLION FOR STIPENDS FOR
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS THAT ACCEPT
STATE SUBSIDIES INCLUDING STATE
PRESCHOOLS. STIPENDS WILL BE.
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER ELIGIBLE CHILD.
EIGHTY MILLION PROVIDE MORE
THAN EIGHT THOUSAND CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO I'M SEVENTY SIX MILLION TO
EXTEND THE CARE OF CHILDREN ON
TEMPORARY SUBSIDIES THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. ON AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ON TO
ENSURE EXPEDIENT ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING AND SOCKS TO PROVIDERS.
AND FAMILIES- ADDITIONALLY WE
ARE PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTEEN PAID NON OPERATIONAL
DAYS FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
THAT ACCEPT THAT EXCEPT ST
ROGERS. THESE ADDITIONAL NON
OPERATIONAL DAYS WE PAID FOR
WITH UNUSED CHILD CARE FUNDS
PROVIDED ON THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. ADDITIONALLY FOR
THE REMAINDER FUNDS OF THAT
NINE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR MILLION-
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
ALONG WITH THE ALONG WITH CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED ON WHICH
REPRESENTS CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
TO ESTABLISH A WORKGROUP. TO
IDENTIFY THE ALLOCATION OF THE
REMAINING FEDERAL FUNDS AND
PRIORITIES IMPACTING THE CHILD
CARE FIELD. AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY COMMENTS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE OHIO.
OBSERVER TED LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO IN A RECENT
ANALYSIS WE PROVIDED ISSUES THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER TO
MOST EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES DURING
THE PANDEMIC WITH ADDITIONAL
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER OPTIONS AT THE STATE
COULD IMPLEMENT QUICKLY GIVEN
THE IMMEDIATE ISSUES CREATED BY
THE CLUB IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY.
SO THIS INCLUDES USING EXISTING
PROGRAMS EXTENDING EXISTING
PANDEMIC ACTIONS IN USING
SIMPLE ALLOCATION METHODS TO
GET FUNDS QUICKLY TO PROVIDERS
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER SPREADING FUNDS ACROSS
THE CURRENT YEAR IN THE BUDGET
YEAR SO THIS INSURES A STATE
CONSISTING TEMPORARY SUPPORT
FOR A LONGER TIME PERIOD. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO CONSIDER
MODIFYING. TO EASE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN EARNINGS
THE EXAMPLE WE PROVIDING ALSO
SAYS WEAVING FAMILY FEAST.
WOULD FURTHER NOTE THAT THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE IS A ONE TIME
FUNDING SO DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PRIORITIZE
USING ONE TIME FUNDS TO PROVIDE
TEMPORARY SLOTS FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS. THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER PROVIDING
SIMILAR FUNDING WITH THE
ADDITIONAL CCTV G. FUNDING TO
CONTINUE TO. PROVIDE SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE FOR FAMILIES BUT
WITHOUT ONGOING FUNDING HOWEVER
FAMILIES RECEIVING TEMPORARY
SLOTS WILL EVENTUALLY BE
DISSING ROLLED. WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT ON PAGE TWELVE AND
YOUR AGENDA HAS A LIST OF
REQUESTS FROM STAKEHOLDERS
REGARDING THESE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS THIS INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL DOCTOR SOUGHT STATE
BINS WE BEGAN WITH FEES
EXTENDING HOLD HARMLESS IT. BUT
YOU CAN SEE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF REQUESTS
IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE TWELVE.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
ARE NOW MOVES TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING
AGAIN AERONAUTICAL MARC AND
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE%
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO. EMPLACED ORDER
WAS ISSUED IN MARCH TWENTY
FIFTEEN HE HAS ADMINISTERED
FIVE HUNDRED. YES MA'AM YOU'RE
A LAVENDER FRIENDS TO SUPPORT
SHORT TERM EMERGENCY CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS BEING BUDGET FOR
CLOSURES AND HELD HARMLESS FOR
LOWER CHILD ATTENDANCE. ET
SUPPLIES WEEDING NEEDS AS WELL
AS SECONDS GRADERS IN
ADDITIONAL REACHED OVER THIRTY
MANAGEMENT BULLETINS PROVIDING
GUIDANCE TO THE FIELD LEAST
OVER THREE HUNDRED I THINK USE
THAT WEAPON ARE SPRINGFIELD.
GUIDANCE IN HOW TO INTERESTING
MMHM WE. AGREE TO. I HAVE
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS AND
ALTHOUGH THE REGIONAL. WHERE
ARE CONSULTANTS STAFF ARE
CONNECTING THE- TO PROVIDE TO
ASSISTANCE MORE MENTORING.
SESSIONS ON RESULTS AND SUCCESS
AS WELL AS ADDRESSING MENTAL
ISSUES. INFORMAL AS WELL AS THE
AND- DESPITE EVERYTHING THAT WE
ALL HAVE COME DIçN WE KNOW
THAT THE STUFF. ISSUES
INCLUDING WITH STAFF. FOR
CLOSURES ARE BROWN RESTAURANTS
DIFFICULTY. WHAT AN INCREASE
PROGRAM COSTS TO ADDRESS HEALTH
SAFETY STAFF SUPPORTING IN
PERSON DISTANCE LEARNING SENATE
ADDRESSING. AND WALDRON.
KNOWING THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
THAN FIELD ARE SO THAT EARLIER
THIS ONTH CALIFORNIANS DID
LIST THE NINE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
MILLION AN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
HEALTHCARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
PLAN- EARLIER. IT'S THESE ONES
ARE NOT YET BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
TO THAT OF THE- HOWEVER WE ARE.
ABOUT KEEPING FUNDS WILL BE
READY TO DISTRIBUTE THEM BASED
ON PRIORITIES SET BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION.
AS THE AGENDA NANCE MANY OF THE
PRIORITIES THAT WERE LISTED AS
TRIGGERS FOR FUTURE. EIGHT ARE
YOU BUYING THAT BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE- MUNITIONS
YEAH HUNDRED TEN. DOLLARS FOR
THE PHONE. ORGANS CAN HELP
NEEDS OF. OVER TIME. THE SPEED
IN WHICH THE DEPARTMENT CAN GET
THE OUT TO FIELD WILL RELEASE
ON THE THAT ARE. MY NOW WITH
THIS. ON THE MINISTRY
PRIORITIES. AND INCLUDES. AS
PART OF THAT PEOPLE CAN.
REGULATE IN PROCESS. IN WHICH-
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ASK. AS THE
L. A. L. MENTION AMEREN AND
KEPT IN THE THAT MUSEUMS
ALLOCATION. AND INSTEAD IT
PANDEMIC ACTIONS WILL BE FOR TO
IMPLEMENT IN A COMPLETELY NEW
CAR OR IT COMES. MISSION AND-
WITH WORK TO POTENTIAL USES THE
FINE IN. NOW THERE'S AN APP
DEGREE THAT THE SPENDING SHARED
WITH THE TARGET WRITERS UNION.
AND WHY OF THE GREAT APPETITE
TABLE PROTECT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT AND WE OPERATE IN
THEIR EVEN FUTURE. NOT TOO MANY
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ACTUALLY HAS
THE EIGHTH WHICH HAS CARE
EDUCATION IN IT AS WELL THAT
HELP AND EXPAND AT TO PRESCHOOL
THROUGH THE IN THE CARE. IN
LINE WITH THE L. A. L. REALLY
LOOK AT. IT THE USE OF THESE
PLANS TO DO THINGS LIKE WAIVING
FEES FOR ALL THE INS AND
FLAGGED THE NEED FOR CONTINUED
HOME FOR MOST FOR BOTH THE
DIRECT CONTRACT DID AND GOT
YOUR PROGRAMS HE'S ACTIONS WITH
STABILIZE THE ENTIRE SYSTEM AND
REDUCE SOME OF THE INDUSTRY
REMAINS. THEIR PROGRAMS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH WHILE. THEY
ADDRESS ALL THE- NINETEEN
MINISTRY. ALSO HEARD THERE'S A
ONGOING NEED FOR ALL FROM. BOTH
DIRECT DIRECT. ABOUT AS AS NON
FLIGHTS JUST THE PRICE CARE
FIELD TO RECEIVE A STATE
MINISTER. THAT ADDRESS YOU JUST
BECAUSE- BUSINESS. ON THE WEB
OUT OF THE SIMILAR BECAUSE YOU
COME THE ROOF CAL ABOUT. EVAN
LOW. AS WITH IT FOR MONTH
VOLATILITY THERE ARE STILL THAT
DO HAPPEN. YOU'RE REALLY
ADDRESSING TO OF THIS CAN.
ARKANSAS ARCHES RIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER MORE. THANK YOU OUR
SYSTEM QUICK. TO LEAD OFF AND
IT A QUESTION FOR. THE FUNDING
TO. HANDLE ANALOG DISK. OF
THEIR COM. ON AT SIX COULD BE
TO SUPPORT CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
TO GET THEM THINGS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND THE- DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION JUST SPOKE TO THOSE
SAME RECOMMENDATIONS- DO YOU
HAVE A REACTION TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. HELLO
AGAIN SIR BERNARD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YES SO
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE YEAR
WE'VE AND RESPONSIVE TO WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION HAS
BEEN SAYING- AND WORKING WITH
OUR LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS AS
WELL. I'M TO ADDRESS ALL THE
NEEDS OF THE CHILD CARE FIELD-
AND SO UP TO THIS POINT LIKE I
MENTIONED MY OPENING
STATEMENTS- WE WE'VE FUNDED
VARIOUS DIFFERENT POLICIES
BASED ON A LOT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS SO WE'RE
CERTAINLY WILLING TO CONTINUE
THAT AND CONTINUE WORKING WITH.
OUR PARTNERS. MAYBE TO
SUMMARIZE WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
THEY MADE RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU'RE REALLY WILLING TO
CONSIDER THEM RIGHT NOW YOUR
RECOMMENDATION DOESN'T CONTAIN-
ASCENT RIGHT. I BELIEVE THERE
IS A LINE THAT WAS WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING IN TERMS OF THE
NEWEST AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN IN THE
PROPOSAL THAT CAME OUT IN THE
LANGUAGE AND WITH THE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT LAST WEEK-
WITH WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- BUT WE'RE ALWAYS
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH THEM
AND CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WELL. TO AND
WOULD YOU PLEASE LET US KNOW-
AS WELL BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE
AN INTEREST IN THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS OTHER BY
SENATORS IT ON THE CZECH. CARE
EGGMAN TO HAVE QUESTIONS
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU CHIRLA
OR DEBT JUST TO CLARIFY- THE
FUNDING FLOWS HERE- SO- THE
FEDERAL ACTS PROVIDE NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR MILLION AND
SUPPLEMENTAL- C. C. D. B. G.
FUNDS. BUT WE ALSO HAD AN SP
EIGHT TWENTY- TRIGGERS FOR THE
FIRST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
HOWEVER UNDERSTAND SOME OF THAT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION WAS
ALREADY COVERED BY PREVIOUS
FEDERAL FUNDS BUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF.
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
IN TERMS OF AN OUT OF IS THE
WHOLE NINE OR SIXTY FOUR
MILLION WE'RE WORKING WITH IS
IT. F. PART OF THAT BECAUSE
THIS SB EIGHT TWENTY HOW MUCH
OF THAT SO CONTINUE TO SPEAK
TO. AND THEN ALSO HOW LONG FOR
THE NINE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
MILLION IS THERE A TIME LINE
WHICH WE NEED TO EXPAND THE
FUNDS BY. SO CAN CAN- FINANCE
EARLIER PLEASE PROVIDE SOME
MORE SPECIFICITY AS TO WHAT
KIND OF FUNDS ARE WE WORKING
WITH HERE WITH THAT THE- WITH
HR. ONE THIRTY THREE. I GUESS I
THE SERVER OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YES. YEAH AND I CAN
HELP ELUCIDATE SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT PART BECAUSE IT IS A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSING- SO TO BE
CLEAR AND SB EIGHT TWENTY-
THERE WAS A SECTION THAT
APPROPRIATED THE DURING YOUR
FIFTEEN MILLION AND THEN THERE
WAS ANOTHER SECTION- THAT. FOR
UP WITH A POSITIVE TRIGGER FOR
THREE HUNDRED MILLION- IF WE
WERE TO RECEIVE MORE FEDERAL
FUNDS- AND WE DID RECEIVE MORE
FEDERAL FUNDS- IN THE FORM OF
THE HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
FROM. THE CORONAVIRUS REALLY
pUSED FOR SOME OF THE SB EIGHT
TWENTY PURPOSES- INCLUDING
EXTENDING THE FAMILY FEE
WAIVERS FOR REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THE FAMILY FEW WAIVERS- AND
EXTENDING. ABOUT YOUR BASE LOTS.
EMERGENCY VOUCHER SLOTS I'M
EXTENDING ACCESS FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS AND- TO SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT THE WHAT'S
THERE- MY COLLEAGUE AT THE BARN
EDUCATION- IS NOBLE MORGAN WAS
SAYING EARLIER TO- SO THAT
FUNDING NINE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DID UP HE'S A LOT OF
THE NEED. FOR THOSE PURPOSES
ARE OUTLINED IN SB EIGHT TWENTY
SO WITH THIS BRAND NEW TRYING
TO FEDERAL FUNDS ON THAT JUST
CAME FROM THIS MOST RECENT ACT
PASSED BY CONGRESS. WE REALIZE
THAT SOME OF THOSE SOME OF THAT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
POT I WAS ALREADY A SORT OF
TAKING CARE OF IN TERMS OF
HAVING ENOUGH FUNDING NEEDED
FOR THOSE PURPOSES OUR
OUTLINED- AND SO. SOME OF WHAT
WAS IN THAT LANGUAGE HARPER
WASN'T A FULLY OPERATIONAL IN
TERMS OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
THE FIELD AND WHAT WE NEED TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO NOW- AND SO
THE PROPOSAL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION I'M JUST PUT
OUT. A IN TERMS OF ALL THE NW.
ALL THE NEW PURPOSES FOR THE
FUNDING- INCLUDING YOU KNOW THE
VOUCHER THEY SLOTS EXTENDING
ACCESS TO JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- IN THE STIPENDS.
AND THEN ON OPERATIONAL DAYS-
BILLS- WE CREATED AND YOU KNOW
IN IN DISCUSSION WITH- THE
UNION AND- LISTENING TO THE
VARIOUSNEEDS IN THE FIELD. AND
SO THOSE ARE NOT PERFECTLY
MIRROR WASN'T SB TWENTY- BUT IT
IS TO BE RESPONSIVE TO WHAT THE
FIELD REALLY NEEDS RIGHT NOW
OKAY SO YOU SO JUST TO CLARIFY-
GIVEN SB EIGHT TWENTY. AND I
REALIZE THAT HE SAID THERE ARE
SOME MODIFICATION. THERE ARE
STILL A HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
LEFT IN THAT TRIGGERED THAT
WOULD BE TRIGGERED ARE WE PLAN
TO SUSPEND. SB EIGHT TWENTY.
THERE ARE PROPOSAL IS. IS YOU
KNOW IN THE SPIRIT OF WHAT WAS
IN THE POSITIVE TRIGGER IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING THE NEEDS
OF THE FIELD I'M JUST REALIZING
THAT SOME OF. THE WAY THAT THE
LANGUAGE WAS WRITTEN MADE IT SO
THAT IT ONE AND ALLOW US TO.
EXPEDITE SOME OF THSE FUNDS AS
QUICKLY AS THE FIELD WOULD
NEED- TO ADDRESS US. TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE- CONSEQUENCES OF
THE GROUP IN NINETEEN CAN TO
MAKE AND SO THIS PROPOSAL- IN
THIS EARLY ACTION LANGUAGE. I'M
GETS OUT MORE OF THE PATH OF
THE PACKAGE THAT ALLOWS US TO
GET FUNDS OUT QUICKLY RIGHT NOW
SO OKAY. WE DIDN'T QUITE ANSWER
MY QUESTION SO. WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING A NEW SO WE HAVE A
HUNDRED. IF IN LESS I GOT MY
MATH WRONG WE HAVE A HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION LEFT IN THE S.
B. A. TWENTY TRIGGER POSITIVE-
AND SO. WE'RE YOUR IN YOUR
PROPOSAL YOUR PLANE TO SAY NO
WE TURN THAT OFF WE HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE RIGHT OR WE ARE
DOES THAT SB EIGHT TWENTY
TRIGGER STILL CONTINUE. FOR THE
REMAINING HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION. YES SO THE NEW FUNDING
DOES NOT DOES NOT PERFECTLY
TAKE FROM THE LANGUAGE OF SB
EIGHT TWENTY OKAY. ALL RIGHT
AND THEN THE OKAY SO WERE OKAY
AND THEN D. NINE UNDER SIXTY
FOUR MILLION WHEN DO WE HAVE TO
EXPAND THAT BY HIS DISCO UNTIL
WHEN. THE NINE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR TO BE GOT FROM H. R. ONE
THIRTY THREE AS OUR TIMELINE ON
THAT OR IT'S A BLOCK GRANT SO I
PRESUME IS THERE A TIME WE HAVE
TO SPEND IT BY ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. YES IF YOU
LIVE ANY TO BE SPENT. ABOUT OF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD I DON'T
KNOW- IMMEDIATELY- I MISS NO
MORE AND I DON'T KNOW IF FROM
CITY REMEMBER OFF THE TOP OF
YOUR HEAD. YEAH. I'M ALSO SIR
BUT HE WAS PARTNER I THINK IT'S
AT TYPICALLY WE HAVE THREE
YEARS TO GET THROUGH THE FUNDS
BUT I AM TRYING TO GET THE
FINAL NUMBER. SO YOU CAN YOU
CAN GET BACK TO ME ON THAT AND
OKAY BECAUSE I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
THAT SOME OF THIS IS WE WANT TO
BE SURE WE MEET THE NEED THAT
PURPOSE OF THE MONEY. ALSO YOU
KNOW TRYING TO AVOID CLIFFS AND
SO FORTH THAT MAY HAPPEN- SO
KNOWING WHAT THAT TIME LINE IS
BECAUSE ALSO IN. SOME SENSES
WHEN THIS MONEY RUNS OUT. WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN WHAT STATE MAY
NEED TO DO TO. PICK UP ON
WHATEVER FURTHER TRANSITION
THERE NEEDS TO BE SO WE DON'T
AGAIN LEAVE PEOPLE IN A CLASS.
OF EXCEL WOULD BE HELPFUL TO.
BUT DIAGRAM. PERHAPS OF HEALTH
THIS THAT OUT HOW THE MONEY'S
GOING TO GO. AND THEN IN TERMS
OF AND I CERTAINLY SUPPORT-
MAIN THE THINGS. THAT WOULD PUT
FORWARD IN THE- MO YOU BUT TO
HAVE IT DO YOU HAVE AN EXPENSE
FOR. THE- THINK WHAT'S BEEN
AGREED TO IN THE M. O. U. SO
HOW MUCH HOW MUCH OF HOW MUCH
IS THAT GOING TO COST. ASSUME
THAT'S GOING TO COME OUT THE
NINE OF SIXTY FOUR MILLION BUT
DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH THAT IS.
YEAH SO TO BE. CLEAR IT'S- IT'S
A HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION
WILL BE PROVIDED TO VOUCHER
BASED PROGRAMS AND THE GENERAL
CHILD CARE PROGRAM FOR THE
STIPENDS AND A HUNDRED MILLION-
TO THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
FOR SITE PLANS- AND I APOLOGIZE
IN THE- AGREEMENT. ON IT JUST
INCLUDES THE STIPENDS FOR- WHAT
IS BEING BARGAINED WITH THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME PROVIDERS
UNLESS EXAM PROVIDERS SO. THAT
WOULD JUST BE THE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR MILLION- AND THEN BE.
ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN PAY NON
OPERATIONAL DATA- AND SO THOSE
COSTS ARE BEING ABSORBED WITHIN
UNUSED CHILD CARE FUNDS FROM
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
OKAY HOW MUCH. I KNOW YOU SAID
IT'S ABSORBED BUT HOW MUCH.
THERE WAS AN ORIGINAL I BELIEVE
SIXTY TO SIXTY TWO MILLION FOR
THOSE PURPOSES FOR THE NON
OPERATIONAL DAYS AND ALL OF
THEM WERE USED SO. WE ARE
PROPOSING TO REPURPOSE THOSE
FUNDS FOR ADDITIONAL DAYS OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO- I APPRECIATE
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING THAT.
THIS IS A BUDGET COMMITTEE SO
I'D LIKE TO HAVE THE NUMBER.
ITSELF MAYBE PERHAPS YOU CAN
GET TO ME IN THE FUTURE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE IT IN FRONT OF YOU
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU. AND MAYBE
IF I COULD. DO A QUICK FOLLOW
UP TO CENTER PANTS QUESTION.
BECAUSE THE PROPOSAL EXCEPT FOR
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PEACE
WAS NOT INCLUDED IN OUR- AGENDA
BECAUSE IT WAS NOT PUBLIC YET
YET EVERYBODY'S TALKING ABOUT
SO IS IT CLEAR THAT- THAT IS
THAT OUT OF YOUR PROPOSAL OUT.
EVERY ON A FRIENDS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAID IT
IS A LIFE MADE PUBLIC- ON
FRIDAY FRIDAY EVENINGS OF THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS NOW
POSTED ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WEBSITE- SO THAT
EVERYONE CAN SEE AND THE TOTAL
AGREEMENT. IS FOR OUR PROPOSAL
IS FOUR HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION
AT THAT KIND OF VIRUS RELIEF.
OKAY AND IS THAT PART OF. THEIR
FORTS PART OF EARLY ACTION
RIGHT. IT IS BEING PROPOSED AS
A PART OF THAT OKAY MAMA. HE
ARE PROJECTED TO PUT IT UP ON A
FRIDAY NIGHT AT THE START OF A
THREE DAY HOLIDAY WEEKEND WHERE
WE HAD THE HEARING THE FIRST
THING IN THE MORNING OF THE
WORKING DAY AFTER SO. JUST IN
THE FUTURE MAYBE AN EMAIL TO
FLAG IT AS WELL AS JUST POSTING
IT OUT THERE AND THEN WE WON'T
HAVE THE CONFUSION OF APPEARING
NOT TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT
WASN'T READY BY OUR AGENDA
PACKET. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
SENATORS BEFORE WE WE'VE ISSUED
TO. I DIDN'T WANT TO MOVE TO
ISSUE THREE WHICH IS THE CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS TRANSITION. AND
WE HAVE DIFFERENT PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE KIM
JOHNSON JENNIFER TROYA SELINA
CHOW FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. SIR NEVILLE
MORGAN AGAIN AND LISA MYSTRA
THE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND SARAH CORTEZ FROM
THE OF. MUCH TAKE FROM CAN THE
ORDER DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THEN ALEJO SLOWLY
BEGAN- SINCE WE SET THERE NOW
IS A PROPOSAL THAT I GUESS WE
DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO ANALYZE
THIS- I GUESS I'D ASK THE
CHAIRS BUT WHAT THE PROCESS BY
WHICH WILL ACTUALLY. REVIEW THE
ACTUAL PROPOSAL SINCE WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE CHANCE TO DO THAT HERE
THIS MORNING. ARE WE LOOKING
AT. A RE VISIT AT A FUTURE
HEARING. OF OUR- AND THIS IS
EARLY ACTION SO I ASKED HER
PERHAPS IT GOES TO THE FULL
BUDGET SUB AT SO PERHAPS YES.
BECAUSE I THINK THERE WILL BE A
HEARING ON EARLY ACTION ON
THEIR HEARING EARLY ACTION TO
BE A REPORT ON IT WITH THAT.
AND AS MUCH AS WE WOULD HAVE
LIKED TO HAVE DISCUSSED IT HERE
SINCE WE'RE TALKING THE WHOLE
BREATH IT JUST DIDN'T HAPPEN
THE SEQUENCE OF EVENTS SO I
THINK IT'LL BE DONE AS PART OF
EARLY ACTION. OKAY THANK YOU
FOLLOW. UP ON THAT. OKAY THEN
WILL MOVE TO A THREE AND A
GONNA START WITH THE- OF SO
SERVICE FALL BY THE TO. OF
FOLLOWED BY THE ALEJO WHAT DOES.
IT WHOEVER OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES REPRESENTATIVES
IS GOING TO PRESENT POLICE
PRESENT. WELCOMING CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU
WANTED TO JUST PROVIDE SOME
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEWS UNDER
INTENSE RELATED TO THE
TRANSITION AS WE WORK THROUGH.
THE QUESTIONS OUTLINED IN YOUR
AGENDA WITH THE TEAM HERE SO
JUST TO THE EARLIER COMMENTS
MADE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT THE OVER ARCHING GOALS OF
THE SYSTEM ARE CONTINUING THAT
SUPER STRONG IMPORTANT.
DEVELOPMENTAL AND EDUCATIONAL
START FOR OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN
AND LEARNERS AND CERTAINLY
CONNECT IN SUPPORT OF THE WORK
FORCE ADD TO THE NEEDS THE
CHILD CARE NEEDS THAT THEY
HAPPENED SO JUST WANTED TO
APLIK FAT IN OUR- ABSOLUTE
COMMITMENT TO MAINTAIN
PARTNERSHIP IN CONNECTION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
ARE MOVING FORWARD- JUST IN
TERMS OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
YOU JUST HAD TO BE ON THE- ARE.
WHAT'S WHAT THE PANDEMIC HAS
YIELDED IN TERMS ADDS IMPACTS
ADD TO THE POINTS MADE BY CHAIR
ADDS AND BRAKEMAN EARLIER ON
YES WE WILL HAVE AS A SYSTEM.
AS SOME REBUILDING TO DO. AND
TO MAKE HAS AND I CERTAINLY
DEVON AND ON BOTH THE FAMILIES
AND- THOSE. FAMILIES POVERTY. A
PRE MAKE AND I WAS THE PANDEMIC
HASN'T SUED BUT ALSO AGAIN THE
WORK FORCE IN THE PROGRAM SAID
EARLIER COMMENTS MADE RELATED
TO CLOSURES SO WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY HAVE SOME REBUILDING
AND SUPPORT WILL NEED TO DO
THAT FOR PROGRAMS ALONG THE WAY
AND RECOGNIZE THAT- AS WE'RE
WORKING. ON STRENGTHENING AND
BUILDING ON THE GREAT WORK DONE
TO DATE WITH THE SYSTEM THESE
WILL BE SOME ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES THAT WILL FACE AS A
STATE. AND THE FEDERAL RELIEF
IS CRITICAL AND JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE ABOUT LAST
CONVERSATION TO NOT NOT UNLIKE
ANY OTHER PLACES ACROSS. THE
WEB DESPITE THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE DONE TO
DATE IN TERMS OF GETTING
SUPPORT ADDRESSING IMMEDIATE
NEEDS NOT ONLY. FISCAL AND
FINANCIAL RESOURCES BUT ALSO IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF POLICY
FLEXIBILITIES THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE. TO HELP FAMILIES
MAINTAIN SERVICES I HAVE
DESTRUCTION AND BREAK IN
SERVICES AND ALSO AGAIN TO
SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE IN.
ADMINISTERING NEW GUIDELINES
AND SUPPORTING AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY AT THEIR WORK FORCE AND
ALSO THE CHILDREN THAT THEY
SERVE. IN ADDITION RIGHT WE
HAVE ACROSS THE SYSTEM THE
CHANGING LANDSCAPE O THAT
THAT- ADDITION A BARGAINING
INTO THE SYSTEM AND TO THE
POINTS MADE EARLIER AROUND
RATES. AND THE RATE SETTING
THAT IS CERTAINLY WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THAT BARGAINING IN
AGAIN AND WE ANTICIPATE HAVING
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION. ALONG
THE WAY- I'M ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT IN TERMS OF THE WORK TO
DATE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS I REALLY
WANT TO RESHAPE NECKLACE THAT
APARTMENT EDUCATION FOR WORKING
ON BOTH. ONBOARDING
TRANSITIONING SUPPORTING US AND
UNDERSTANDING YEAH EXACTLY
WHERE PROGRAMS AND POLICIES AND
PROCESSES ARE TO DATE- AMONGST
THEIR OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES.
AS WE OUT WORK ON THIS
TRANSITION IT'S EFFECTIVE JULY
ONE AT THIS YEAR. WE ARE.
CORPORATION BUT KEEP PRINCIPLES
THAT YEAH THAT SOME OF WHICH
HAVE ALREADY BEEN. AB ABOUT THE
SYSTEM DATE BUT REALLY WOULD
JUST HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU. APPS
WANTING TO ENGAGE. AND THE- TO
SAYS CHRISTIANS AND SETTING.
SEES AND CERTAINLY OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN HOLDING NUMEROUS.
LISTENING SESSIONS ACROSS THE
FIELDS SESSIONS ON TOPICS BASED
ON WHAT THE FIELD HAS TOLD US
TO DATE- TO BE ABLE TO
INFLUENCE AND STEERING ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES. IN SUPPORT
SEVENTY ONE AT AT PROVIDE. ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE DATA AS
BUSINESS MENTIONS AB
UNDERSTANDABLE WORKING EARLIER
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ALSO STRENGTHENING THESE DATA
SYSTEMS MAKING THE CONNECTIONS
AND TIES TO THE GREATER HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES AND
SOME OF OUR SISTER DEPARTMENTS
AGENCIES. AND USE THAT DATA TO
DRIVE. THE OUTCOMES ARE ALONG
THE WAY AND MAKE MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS ALONG THE WAY. AND
ALSO ONE UP LIFT. DRESSING
INEQUITIES IN THE SYSTEM
CERTAINLY NOT ONLY IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING
BUT ALSO. TO THE ASSEMBLY
SLEEPING COMMISSION'S REPORT
AND AFTER A RECENT CHECK WE
RECOGNIZE AGAIN BASED
ESPECIALLY BASED ON. THE CAN
DIRECT AND WHAT DOESN'T SEEM TO
THAT WE DO HAVE MANY INEQUITIES
TO ADDRESS ACROSS THE BOARD
INCLUSIVE EXISTENCE YOU'RE SOME
OF THE PRINCIPLES THAT HAVE
DRIVEN. OUR ENGAGEMENTS IN THE
IN THIS TRANSITION. YOUR BILL
WILL CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD. I
WE ARE EX. ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES
TO STRENGTHEN CONNECT BACK TO
THE HELP AND HUMAN SERVICES AGE
IN THE RACE TO MAKE SOME CALLS.
X. WOULD BE ITEMS LIKE OUR
VERIFICATION HAVE PROCESS WHERE
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT A FAMILY. IS AND WE ARE
ALSO BESTSELLER GRADING THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIONS HAS BUILT A
AGAIN FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
POVERTY. AND THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE AT LEAST CONNECTIONS
ABOUT FULLER RATE- IS
SEAMLESSLY ONE AS CERTAINLY
REDUCE BURDENS AT TO. ADD THOSE
ADMINISTERING PROGRAMS AS WELL
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE KINDS
OF OPPORTUNITIES IDENTIFICATION
HELPS HELPS. ESSENTIALLY HOW
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION ON THE
BACK END FOR ALL OF THIS
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS. ABOUT
WHEN ONE FAMILIES BEING CHECKED
IN TERMS OF THEIR INCOME
ELIGIBILITY FOR ONE PROGRAM
THAT CAN HAPPEN ACROSS THE
BOARD THAT IS WITHOUT HAVING TO
HAVE. OTHERS ADDITIONAL STEPS
MADE SO THERE'S SOME
OPPORTUNITY THERE WE ALSO AS
CERTAINLY AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF
OUR AT FAMILIES AT WORK FORCING
COMMUNITIES WANT TO INFUSE.
TRAUMA INFORMED OR HEALING FOR
INFORMED APPROACHES ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. BUILDING ON THE WORK OF
FOR EXAMPLE OUR ART CALIFORNIA
STATE GENERAL DOCTOR. BURKE
HARRIS ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ADDRESSING THOSE
GOING FORWARD. AND ALSO EARLY
INTERVENTION OPPORTUNITIES AT
WHICH I KNOW. THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AT THREE HAS
ENGAGED ON WITH OUR DEPARTMENT
THE LITTLE SERVICES HOW ARE WE
ENSURING THE SCREENS ARE
HAPPENING. AND I CONNECTIONS
BEING HAPPY MAKING ME VERY
EARLY ON FOR CHILDREN ACROSS
COMMUNITY SO. AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING SEPARATE YOU
DO ENGAGE WITH YOU TODAY. ABOUT
SOME OF THE- ASIANS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE ENTRY. AND ARE TO. I
AND I WILL TRAINS BACK DOWN
OVER TO OUR THE DRESS CHEN
TRONG. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
JOHNSON JENNIFER TROY YEAH AM
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HAPPY TO BE HERE WITH
YOU THIS MORNING I JUST WANT TO
ADD. A LITTLE BIT MORE AND I'VE
SOME DETAILS SURROUNDING A
SURROUNDING THE TRANSITION
ACTIVITIES THAT WE'VE ENGAGED
IN TO DATE. IN CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH CD. I'M IN
PARTICULAR YOUR AGENDA LEAVES
OUT THOSE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE
TRANSFERRING FROM CD USE
WALMART'S. THOSE PROGRAMS WILL
BE JOINING THE STAGE ONE HOW
WORKS HOW CARE PROGRAM THE
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER CHILDREN. AS
WELL AS THE CHILD CARE
LICENSING PROGRAM AND A NUMBER
OF NUTRITION PROGRAMS INCLUDING
CALFRESH THAT. ARE ALREADY
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
TOGETHER WITH C. D. E. AND ALSO
SOLICITING QUITE A BIT OF
FEEDBACK FROM STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE FIELD. AND THROUGHOUT THAT-
FALL AND- INTO THIS WINTER- WE
HAVE STIRRED UP A DEDICATED
PUBLIC WEBPAGE- IT WAS LAUNCHED
IN AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
IT ALLOWS- AND ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK TO
REST REFORMS IT ALSO HAS
OFFERED SURVEYS IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH. AND OFFERED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO ENGAGE. IN OTHER WAYS WITH
RESPECT TO THE TRANSITION- WE
HAVE RECEIVED OVER A HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS FEEDBACK VIA A LIVE
SURVEY THREW THAT FORMAT. WE
HAVE ALSO HELD QUARTERLY
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS ABIT HAVE
ALLOWED INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE
UPDATES- AND THAT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO INVITE
INPUT. AND WE HAD THREE
QUARTERLY MEETINGS THUS FAR
WITH OVER A THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS. WE HAVE ALSO HELD
TOPICALLY SPECIFIC TO OUR
LISTENING SESSIONS ON A VARIETY
OF TOPICS THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT DURING THE TRANSITION
AND BEYOND- IN ORDER TO ENSURE
NO DESTRUCTION AND TO INSURE
THAT WE ARE CAPTURING
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE UPON-
THE STRENGTH OF THE SYSTEM THAT
ALREADY EXIST. THOSE INCLUDED
TOPICS SUCH AS CONTRACTS THE
ISSUES IMPACTING RURAL AREAS IN
PARTICULAR EQUITY AND WHOLE
CHILD WHOLE FAMILY APPROACHES
TO MEETING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES NEEDS. WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL LISTENING SESSIONS
PLANNED COMING UP AND HAVE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED THE ENGAGEMENT
THAT WE'VE RECEIVED FROM SO
MANY PEOPLE. IN THOSE FORMS.
VETERANS ACTIVITIES TO DATE
HAVE ALSO INVOLVED A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PARTNERSHIP IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CDSS AND
CD. OUR TEAMS ARE IN TOUCH ON A
DAILY BASIS WE HAVE DAILY
WEEKLY AND MONTHLY MEETINGS-
THE TOPIC AREAS THAT WERE
FOCUSING ON- EVERYTHING FROM
FACILITIES AND SPACE PLANNING.
YES S. BUILDINGS AND- BUT JUST
A GOAL- ACTIVITIES WE ALSO HAVE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY BOTH TO
SUPPORT THE STAFF AND TO
SUPPORT THE OPERATIONS OF THE
PROGRAM'S. CONTRACTS
REGULATIONS FISCAL POLICY
DEVELOPMENT. HUMAN RESOURCES
AND LABOR RELATIONS IF
SOMEBODY'S IN LICENSING AND OUT
OF THEIR AUDITING MONITORING
AND PROGRAM INTEGRITY. CITY HAS
PROVIDED TO CDSS REALLY
DETAILED WALKTHROUGHS TO HELP
US UNDERSTAND THE WORK FLOW AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN HAVE A
SEAMLESS TRANSITION ON JULY
FIRST AND THAT THERE WOULD BE
NO DISTRACTIONS SYSTEM. BETWEEN
AB CD AND STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE
ALSO RECEIVED QUITE A BIT OF
INPUT ABOUT LONGER TERM
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STRENGTHENING
THE SYSTEM AND MAKING SOME OF
THE KINDS OF CHANGES THAT
DIRECTOR JOHNSON REFERENCED
WITH RESPECT TO OUR INTENT. TO
SERVE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WITH THE QUALITY AFFORDABLE
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM. THAT WILL
COMPREHENSIVELY AND EFFECTIVELY
SUPPORT. THEIR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE SO-
WITH THAT I WILL STOP AND WE DO
ALSO HAVE OUR CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER SALINAS CHILD I'M HERE
WITH US AND THEY THINK SHE'S
PREPARED AS WELL TO ANSWER SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA
IF THAT IS WHERE THE CHAIRS-
WOULD LIKE TO DO NEXT. THE
WORLD AND IT BACK TO YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO QUESTIONS
AFTER EVERYBODY IS PRESENT. SO
IS THERE ANYTHING. ELSE FROM
YOU BEFORE WE MOVED TO THE-
ARBON OF EDUCATE. I DON'T THINK
UNLESS CAMERA HAS ELSE TO ADD
IN THIS INTRODUCTORY THANK YOU
MOVE TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
SHARES MEMBERS THERE NEVER
MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. OVER
THE LAST YEAR'S CD HAS BEEN
DEEPLY COORDINATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO DETERMINE HOW TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THE
TRANSITION WHILE ALSO
MINIMIZING DISRUPTION TO THE
PROGRAM CONTRACTORS CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. DESPITE NOT
RECEIVING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
IS CDS COMMITTED SIGNIFICANT
TIME AND ATTENTION TO
SUPPORTING THE TRANSITION I'D
LIKE TO BRIEFLY CALL OUT SOME
PIECES THAT ARE CD EIGHTEEN HAS
DONE AROUND. TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE SCOPE OF WORK
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THE
TRANSITION. IN SOME INSTANCES
OUR STAFF HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED
TO A 3240% INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
TO REALLY ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS
IN THE PLAN WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSINGTHE PRIORITIES
RELATED TO THE BAND DAMAC AND.
GETTING ADDITIONAL FINDS OUT TO
THE FIELD. OVER ARCHING ME WE
HAVE SHARED. F WITH
INVENTORIES. AND FUNCTIONS AND
HOSTED SEVERAL DOZEN MEETINGS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH CDSS TO
GIVE THEM INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS AND SYSTEMS
TRANSITIONING. MORE
SPECIFICALLY WE'VE DEVELOPED
MATERIALS FOR ENJOYING THAT
PRESENTED AT MORE THAN SIXTY
CREE NEEDS WALK THROUGH
PRESENTATIONS AND FOLLOW UP
MEETINGS. IDENTIFIED DEVELOPED
AND SHARED ABOUT A THOUSAND
FILES THAT INCLUDE PROCEDURES
MANUALS PROCESS THESE. CHARTS
TRAINING ANY COMPREHENSIVE
TRANSITION INVENTORY. IS
INVENTORY IDENTIFIES AND
DESCRIBES A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE SERVICES AND FUNCTIONS AND
INCLUDES OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE ATTACHMENTS OUTLINING
PROCESS SEES AND RESOURCES.
WOULD ALSO IDENTIFY TWELVE
AREAS WHERE AN INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENT OR MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING MAY BE NEEDED. TO
ENSURE TRANSITIONS SUCCESSFUL
HOST JULY FIRST ESPECIALLY IN
AREAS WHERE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
SAYS MAY NOT BE READY TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT IN TERMS OF DATA
SYSTEMS PAYMENT SYSTEMS AND
OTHER CRITICAL FUNCTIONS. IN
ADDITION WE'VE COLLABORATED AND
CONTRIBUTED TO THAT TRANSITION
PLAN THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
IS DRAFTING AS WELL AS THEIR TO
QUARTERLY. TRANSITION REPORTS
TO DATE. AS WE WORK THROUGH THE
TRANSIT TOGETHER WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL. THERE ARE
SEVERAL HE ISSUE AREAS WHERE
DECISIONS STILL NEED TO BE MADE
AND PROVIDED THEM WITH THE KEY
DECISION DOCUMENT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE KNOW THOSE ARE
PRIORITIES IN OUR MEETINGS OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS THAT WE
REALLY CAN ADDRESS THE KEY
CRITICAL AREAS AROUND HUMANS
AND HOW TO ENSURE PAYMENTS
HAPPEN AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
TRANSITION. WE ALSO WANNA FLAG
ANOTHER AREA RESTORE DRESSING
AROUND QUALITY PLANS INSURANCE
AT WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
FOLLOWING THE TRANSITION. WE
KNOW THAT YES HE WILL CONTINUE
TO NEEDED RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
ADDRESS THE CHILD ASSESSMENT
COMPONENTS AND HELPING US.
INSURE THAT SUPPORT COMMUTING
TO G. K. AND BE PART OF A
TRANSITION AND UPDATING THE
PRESCHOOL LEARNING. FOUNDATIONS
AND OTHER RESOURCES. ANOTHER
CHALLENGE WE KNOW THE OUR- IS
PENDING THAT WERE REALLY WORKED
OUT A LONG. THROUGH MULTIPLE.
BUT APART OF FINANCE IN WITH
CDS THAT. IS A VEHICLE TO ALLOW
FOR COUNTRY TRANSFERS BETWEEN
THE GENERAL CHILD CARE CTR
PROGRAMS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. AND
FINALLY THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT MOVING PROGRAMS IN THE
LAST QUARTER OF THE FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR WHICH ENDS
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH AND THE
NECESSARY YEAR AND ACTIVITIES
TO ENSURE THAT BOTH DEPARTMENTS
WE HAVE THE EXPENDITURE DATA.
FOR ONE FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR AND
WE NEED YOUR AND CLOSING OF THE
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS AROUND
THAT FOR THE STATE CONTROLLED
THE- COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. AS
WELL AS REQUIRED FEDERAL.
REPORTING SO AS YOU CAN HEAR
THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF
COMPLEXITIES AS PART OF A
TRANSITION THAT WE ARE ALL
STILL WORKING DILIGENTLY ON. AS
WE WATCHED UCLA. OWES REPORT
AROUND SEVENTY MODIFIED
APPROACHES AROUND THIS WE DO
SHARE SOME SIMILAR CONCERNS TO
THE L. A. L. ABOUT CONTINUING
THE TRANSITION. AS CURRENTLY
PLANNED ESPECIALLY AROUND
ISSUES RELATING TO THE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN STATE
PRESCHOOL AND THE GENERAL CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS THE
CHILD AND ADULT CARE PROGRAM.
OVERALL DIRECT CONTRACTED
PROGRAMS- YOU MINISTERED VERY
DIFFERENTLY FROM THE VOUCHER
PROGRAMS AND YOU HAVE TO MEET
EDUCATION AND QUALITY
STANDARDS. THIS TRANSITION OF
BIPARTITION. CREATES CREATES A
BIFURCATION ACROSS OUR DIRECT.
SERVICE BROWN'S. I NEED A CD
HAS SUCCESS YOU MAY. SEVEN
BEDROOM TRADE NUTRITION YOUR
PROGRAM INCLUDING THAT IN A
CARE PROGRAM WHICH ONLY PLAN.
FOR COMPLYING COMPLEX FEDERAL.
AND MANDY. SESSION WILL IMPACT
BOTH THE OPERATE IN THE SERVER.
WITH THAT DEFEAT RELY AND EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION AN ONGOING
STATE GENERAL FUND TO CONTINUE
ADMINISTERING THE SIX REMAINING
CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS AT CD.
AS WE FOLLOW THIS TRANSITION CD
WILL NEED SIGNIFICANT STAFF
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE CURRENT
LEVELS OF SUPPORT TO
CONTRACTORS I WOULD ACTUALLY BE
MODIFIED LEVELS OF SUPPORT FOR
MANY PROGRAMS WILL BE
TRANSITIONING TO CD ACCESS. AS
WELL AS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE CETINA AND MARK
ADMINISTERING THOSE EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS CITY
WILL ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT 90% OF ITS CURRENT
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
CONTRACTORS SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE CONTRACTORS DOWN
FROM THE SEVENTY FIVE. SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE WE CURRENTLY
START BECAUSE THEY HOLD
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM CONTRACTS SIMILARITY OF
THE THREE OVER THREE THOUSAND
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES AND
CONTRACTORS THAT OPERATE OUR
FEDERAL CHILD NUTRITION
PROGRAMS WE WILL STILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT TWO THOUSAND OF
THEM. AND BECAUSE OF THE OTHER
MEAL PROGRAMS. ASIAN
TRANSFERRING TO THE DEPARTMENT
ESTO SERVICES I'VE REALLY BEEN
IDENTIFIED DUE TO FUNDING AND
FUNCTION. AND THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE MOVING OVER ARE FUNDED BY
FEDERAL CRIMES SUCH AS THE
CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
FIND. BETTER SYSTEM HASN'T BEEN
INVESTED IN SUPPORTING THE
STATE ADMINISTRATION AND THINGS
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. IN ADDITION
BECAUSE MANY CONTRACTORS WILL
HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
MOVING FORWARD. DEPARTMENTS
WILL HAVE NEW WORKFLOW I
RELATED TO CORD MY- DATA
SHARING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND THAT ABOUT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED C. H. YES P.
R. AND CHILD AND ADULT CARE
FOOD CONTRACTORS NEEDING TO
CDSS. 32% ALSO OPERATE ANOTHER
OF OUR CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS
JUST SHOWING YOU SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTING OF COORDINATION
THAT WILL HAVE TO ENSURE
HAPPENS. AS WE ADDRESS
MONITORING ACROSS TO AGENCIES
DATA COLLECTION AND PROVIDING
SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ACROSS THIS THEME
PARTNERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
FOLLOWING THAT LAST ANALYST
THANK YOU AND THEN WILL MOVE TO
THE COLAIO. MORNINGS ARE HAS
ANALYSTS OFFICE I'M SO JUST A
QUICK REMINDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO SHIFT THREE
BILLION AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE TO
CD. OR DVD TO DS US ON THE
BUDGET ALSO SHIFTS THIRTY TWO
MILLION IN STATE OPERATIONS
FROM CD ETS OF BOTH OF THOSE AT
BOTH OF THOSE ACTIONS WOULD BE
COST NEUTRAL. ON THE LASTLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
THIRTEEN MILLION OF NEW
FUNDING- ONGOING FUNDING TO
BACK FILL SOME OF THE POSITIONS
BEING PROPOSED TO TRANSFER TO
THE FROM CD ETS SO THOSE WOULD
BE BACK FILL POSITIONS ACCEDI-
SO THE ADMINISTRATION NOTES IT
WOULD NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT STAFF
TO ADMINISTER THE PROGRAMS
REMAINING AT CD EVEN THE LEVEL
OF STATE. OPERATIONS BEING
SHIFTED. I'M SO WE HAVE A
COMMENTS REGARDING PROPOSED. SO
WE WOULD KNOW THAT TODAY
SEVERAL ELEMENTS OF THE
TRANSITION PLAN THAT ARE STILL
LACKING SOME- SOME KEY DETAILS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE FULL COST OF
THE TRANSITION REMAIN UNCLEAR
AS A STUDY MINISTRATION- NOTED
IT'S CONTINUING TO ASSESS THE
RESOURCES AND STAFFING NEEDED-
WE ALL WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
COSTS WE ARE AWARE OF SO THE
THIRTEEN MILLION A NOTED TO
BACK FILL POSITIONS THAT CD
EAT. ARE MUCH HIGHER THAN
ANTICIPATED GIVEN THAT EXCEED
THAT EXCEEDS THE COST OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WITHDREW LAST
YEAR DUE TO COST CONCERNS AN
OX. ASSEMBLY REFERRING TO THE
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A NEW
DEPARTMENT TO ADMINISTER THESE
PROGRAMS- THE PROPOSAL SHIFTED
TO GO UNDER DSS. FOR AT THE
COST. DUE TO COST CONCERNS- AND
THEN SELECTING NO REGARDING THE
CALL OF THE- IS THAT THE COSTS
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH BEING ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THE SAME LEVEL OF
ADMINISTRATION BUT JUST HAVING
THAT ADMINISTRATION HAPPENED
WITHIN A DIFFERENT STATE
DEPARTMENT THE COSTS ARE NOT
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY SPECIFIC
IMPROVEMENTS TO STATE LEVEL
ADMINISTRATION. THE WE
RECOGNIZE THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THIS TRANSITION AS
PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET PACKAGE GIVEN THE
INFORMATION WE KNOW SO FAR THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
RECONSIDER CONTINUING WITH THE
TRANSITION. AS PLANNED AND HAD
SEVERAL OPTIONS MOVED TO MOVE
FORWARD. THE FIRST OPTION IS TO
STOP THE TRANSMISSION SO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DECIDE THAT
TRANSITIONING CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS AND THE C. A. C. F. HE
THE INTERNSHIP PROGRAM- TO DS
US IS NO LONGER A PRIORITY. SO
THIS WOULD FREE UP THIRTEEN
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
RELATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT A
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. THE
SECOND OPTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE TO DELAY
THE TRANSITION. THIS WOULD
ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION TO
FOCUS THE ENTIRE ATTENTION ON
THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE. AND PLAN
FOR THE TRANSITION ON THE
SLOWER TIME LINE WEEDING
DELAYING THE TRANSITION UNTIL A
YEAR AFTER THE COUP IN NINETEEN
OR AGENCY DECLARATION AS AND IT
WOULD BE A REASONABLE APPROACH.
ON THE IN THE THIRD OPTION
WOULD BE TO MODIFY THE SCOPE OF
THE TRANSITION. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD REDUCE THE NUMBER O
POSITION OF NUMBER PROGRAM
SHIFTING TO DS US. IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES DECIDE TO TAKE
THIS APPROACH WE RECOMMEND
KEEPING THE C. A. C. F. P. THE
NUTRITION PROGRAM THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED TO MOVE AT CD- KEEPING
NOT PROGRAM THAT. SO AND THAT'S
GIVEN THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS FUNDING. THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SHIFTING THIS
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD FURTHER
MINIMIZES SCHOOL OF THE
TRANSITION MY ALSO SHIFTING.
CERTAIN CHILD CARE PROGRAM CITY
EXCESS OF THIS LIKE JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS WOULD BE-
MOVING POWER STAGES TWO AND
THREE- AND HAVING THE REST OF
THE CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
MAINTAIN THAT CD. AND TAKING A
SMALLER SET OF PROGRAMS COULD
BE MORE MANAGEABLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THIS TIME.
WHATEVER THE LEGISLATURE DOES
DECIDE TO DO- WOULD YOU
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS MAINTAINING THE SAME
LEVEL OVERSIGHT CURRENTLY HAS.
WE HAVE SOME SPECIFIC MORE
TECHNICAL ORIENTED-
RECOMMENDATIONS- IN OUR
ANALYSIS TO THIS AND- THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELL I JUS HAVE
ONE QUESTION TO LEAD WITH TO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES- WE JUST
HEARD THAT. OUR CAN. OF THE
TRAIN. AND EVERY SPEAKER TO
ABOUT THE MECHANIC OF THE
TRENDS. NO WAY SORT ADDRESS
WHETHER YOU THINK IT'S ALL
GOING TO ACTUALLY HAPPEN IN THE
TIME FRAME ABOUT THE- SWITCH OF
THE FISCAL YEAR COULD YOU SPEAK
TO THAT. SURE AND YES WE ARE ON
TRACK TO HAVE THE TRANSITION
OCCUR AT JULY FIRST A COUPLE
THINGS APPOINT OUT HERE IN
TERMS OF THAT MORE DETAILED. A
SPECIFIC SET OF THE TRANSITION
PLAN WE ARE ON SCHEDULE TO
PROVIDE THAT ACCORDING IN
ACCORDANCE TO THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE OF THE END OF MARCH SO
THAT WILL BE COMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE END OF.
MARCH AND AS- UNDERSTANDABLE
MORGAN ADMISSIONS AT THAT STAGE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION IS ALSO
SUPPORTED AT THE DEVELOPMENT AT
THAT PLANS OF THE SPECIFICS.
ADD THE POINTS ALSO MADE OUT BY
THE SEVERAL WORK AND OUT THERE
ARE COMPONENTS OF FOR EXAMPLE
YEAR IN CLOSE OUT OF FISCAL
BOOKS THAT MIGHT BE HONEST
FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR CYCLE
EXCEPT IRAQ. WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH THOSE DETAILS RIGHT NOW
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS TO WHAT THINGS
NEED TO BE CLOSED. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT
POTENTIALLY WILL. HAPPEN POSTED
JULY ONE AND I AM IN WHICH
THINGS WERE IMMEDIATELY- SB
TRANSITIONING OVER. PART OF-
THE SIMPLE MORGAN'S COMMENTS
RELATED TO SOME OF THE
CONTRACTORS THAT THE MAINTAIN
RELATIONSHIPS ABOUT. CERTAINLY
IMPACT THE DATA SYSTEM SO IN
SOME CASES WHAT WILL BE CHIU
ESSENTIALLY USE ONE SYSTEM YOU
KNOW HOW. PROVIDES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES ALSO TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SYSTEM SO AGAIN.
WE ARE A LEADING ANY BURDENS ON
THAT PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS. OF
COURSE OVER TIME- ALSO LOOKING
TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THOSE
DATA SYSTEMS INCORPORATE THEM
INTO OUR LARGER. FAMILY ADDS AS
A SYSTEMS AND PROGRAM SO YES TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. WE ARE
PLANNING ON PROCEEDING WITH
CITY AND JULY ONE TRANSITION
WITH THOSE AT. ADDITIONAL
INFORMATIONAL POINTS IN THE
INFORMATIONAL. POINT GREATLY
ASSISTED. SO THINGS DON'T MATCH
EXACTLY THE STAY FIRST YEAR.
END YOU WOULD. TO DO TO THE END
OF THE FIRST. FOR FISCAL. ENDS
THE WAY THEY'VE BEEN DONE BUT
THAT'S JUST ALL PART OF THE
EXPECTED TRANSITION THAT WOULD
TAKE PLACE ON JULY FIRST IS
THAT CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY THANK YOU- CHAIR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH TIME.
AND I GUESS JUST ON REFLECTION
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT RECENTLY HAS HAS LED US
TO BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF KIDS OUT THERE THAT WE DON'T
KNOW QUITE WHERE THEY ARE BOTH
IN IN OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM AS
WELL AS OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM
IN CALIBRATION CAL WORKS RIGHT
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE MOST
AT RISK. COMMUNITIES AND INTO
IT IN LIGHT OF. DO SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS DO DO YOU DO WE
REALLY THINK NOW IS THE TIME IN
THE MIDDLE THE PANDEMIC TO
CHANGE THE SYSTEM. AND DO EVEN
REALLY HAVE TIME TO DO IT IN
CONTRACTING. THAT PROCESS TO
BEGIN IN MARCH WE'RE NOT QUITE
THERE YET IN ORDER TO BE IN
EFFECT IN JULY. SO AGAIN GIVEN.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF PANDEMIC
WITH SO MANY CHILDREN
UNACCOUNTED FOR RIGHT NOW. DO
WE PRACTICALLY THANK I MEAN
WHAT IS A LOT OF DESCRIBING BUT
DO WE PRACTICALLY THINK. THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO MEET THE
NEEDS IS THIS IS THE BEST PATH
TO MEET THE NEEDS MOST
EFFECTIVELY. DEPARTMENTS OF
SERVICES. YES THERE INCREASED
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND
AGAIN AT WE ARE WE ARE ON TRACK
AND THEY WANT TO JUST AGAIN
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE BELIEVE THAT
THE TRANSITIONAL YIELD IN TERMS
OF CONNECTION TO SOME OF THE
BEST PROGRAMS IN THE GREATER
RATE THAT SHE MENTIONS THAT WE
ARE ON TRACK AND WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT AT
THE IMMEDIATE TRANSITION BUT
ALSO LOOK FOR THOSE AT PROGRAM
POLICY IMPROVEMENTS OVER TIME
ALTERNATE OVER TO OUR CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER SELINA CHOW
SKEET SPECIFICALLY. ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTIONS RELATED TO
CONTRACTING. THE MORNING'S
CHARGING PROPERTY OFFICER FOR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO GIVEN THE MEDIA HURRY OF
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS.
RELATED TO THE SERVICES
FAMILIES AND PAYMENTS FOR WORK
FOR. WHY ARE IS ENSURE THERE IS
DESTRUCTION I'M WILL BE. TIME
AND THE CONTACT WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT OF USUALLY FOR JOHN
ONE. HUNDRED RENEWAL IS ALREADY.
SHE THE WORKING CLOSELY
TOGETHER IDENTIFY SCHEDULE
KILEY AND EXIT OF THE CONTRACT.
EMAIL REPORTING- RELATED
REQUIRE ND WE THAT NEEDS TO BE.
EMBEDDED IN THEIR- BE RENEWED.
ONE BECAUSE THE STATE CONSUMERS.
HE ARE TO GET WITH THE MAN THE
AND EFFICIENT PROCESS TO
COMPLETE THE BUDGET ADDRESS
ALSO NOTICE. WE ARE ALSO
WORKING ON A MISSION TYPE. THE
AMERICAN AND NOT QUITE AWARE IN
WHICH- THESE. THERE'S ALSO H.
TERM INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT
THAT MEANS NECESSARY RECEIPT.
OPTIONS INTO YOUR THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND STATE SCHOOL
YEAR GESTURE GAS AND SERVE IN
SOME OF THE SAME NAME- I
SYSTEMS AND THAT FINANCIAL ON
REPORTING THAT REQUIRED FOR THE
FEDERAL FUNDS. I TO SYSTEMS.
AND SO A LOT OF STAKEHOLDER
INPUT HAS HELPED US IDENTIFY
USED TO ACCESS UNITS STRATEGIES
THE REMOVAL. PLEASE AND
MECHANISM FOR HER. IN STRONG
JULY THE GOALS ARE THE MASTER.
WELL TO HOLD THE STATE ON. AND
ENSURE- THE- BUILDING. IN
CONTRAST RESTRICTED. SO EVEN
THOUGH WE THAT NEEDS TO BE
COMPLETED PRIOR TO THE TRUTH
THE ONGOING PROGRAM IN ALL
ENHANCEMENTS WILL BE X. MUST
FACING OVER TIME AT THE S. TIES
THE PROBLEM HERE RATIONS FALSE
INTO TIMELINE FOR EACH OF
DELIVERABLES THAT WE MENTIONED.
THE SERGEANTS LADY- SO THAT WE
CAN BE PREPARED FOR THE JULY
MONTH START DATE THE- OKAY I
YOUR WEEKLY TO HAVE THOSE READY
AND I GUESS I JUST YOU KNOW ARE
THERE ARE THERE PRACTICAL
BENCHMARKS THAT WERE HITTING.
IN ORDER TO KNOW THAT WORK ON
TRACK DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK
LATER. TO JUST MAYBE NOT DO
THINGS OR TO ASK FOR AN
EXTENSION. I THINK THE
TRANSITION PLAN THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED HUGE PUBLICLY SHARED-
IN MARCH WILL PROVIDE A LOT
MORE DETAILS. BUT CERTAINLY WE
ARE ARE LOOKING TO IDENTIFY THE
SPANISH MARKS. AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH SEATS YOU ARE. HI
THIS IS ONE IN EXACTLY WHAT
TIME SCHEDULE. THOSE THINGS
NEED TO HER INSURANCE SOLUTIONS.
THROUGH RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT
WORKING WITH BENCHMARKS AND
DATA POINTS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
DATA POINTS MATCH WHICH.
BENCHMARKS WE DO THE RISKS THIS-
PROJECT WHOLE PROCESS THAT IS
THAT IS OUR GOAL AND WE ARE
WORKING. WITH MARCH SINGLE- THE
IMMEDIATE. ALL AND I'LL JUST
ADDS THAT- KIND OF AS WE'RE
MAKING THE IMMEDIATE AGAIN ARE
ONE TO MAKE THE PROGRAM FEEL A
CONSISTENT AND HAVE A CONSTANT
FOR ADMIN AND CON. SO IT OF YOU
KNOW MAKING THE CHANGE TO- THE
ACTS CON ITSELF I RELATED TO
THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION AS WELL
UNDER WAY. IN THIS QUARTER
THEIR THEIR TYPICAL PROCESS
THEY DO ALL AB ADD CONTINGENT
UPON BUDGET APPROPRIATIONS TO
HAVE THOSE CONTRACTS ROLLED OUT
SO IN MANY CASES WE ARE LOOKING
TO. MAKE SURE THAT THE NAME
SEARCHING ANY OTHER CHANGES
FUNDING AND CONDITIONS ARE
IMMEDIATELY. NEEDED FOR THE
TRANSITION WILL BE THERE BUT TO
GET ON TO THE EXTENT THAT.
CONTRACTORS WE'VE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM IN THE
IN THE INPUT SESSIONS THAT THAT
THE FIELD WILL BE THE SAME ANY
POLICY CHANGE ANY ANY MAJOR
CHANGES WILL GO THROUGH OUR
TYPICAL PROCESS EASIER WHAT A
BEACON THIS BUDGETARY. AND
DELIBERATION PROCESS OR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SEATS.
DIRECTOR LET ME FOLLOW UP ON
SENATOR EGGMAN QUESTION BECAUSE
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE PICKING UP.
HIS ANGST ABOUT YOUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY COMPLETE THE
TRANSITION AND IF YOU HAVE
THESE BENCHMARKS AND ALL THIS
STUFF. ONE POINT. DO YOU DECIDE
YOU'RE NOT MEETING THE
BENCHMARKS AND YOU COME BACK TO
US AND SAY OKAY AFTER ALL YOUR
CONCERNS TO YOUR. RANKS
TOMORROW HAVE BEEN MET. A I'M
ASKING HOW WE AND GET WITH OR
NOT YOU'RE MEETING THE SPENT. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AGAIN
IT GOING TO BE THE TRANSITION
PLANS THAT TRANSITION PLAN
AGAIN IS DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE
AT THE END OF MARCH AND SO IN
THAT PLAN IS WHERE SOME OF THAT
MORE DETAILED AS SPECIFIC
LAYING OUT OF WHICH- ITEMS WE
CAN EXPECT TO ESSENTIALLY BE
POSTED AS AS YOU. HEARD AT ALL
OF US TODAY TO SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE RECORDING FISCAL CLOSE OUTS
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WILL
BE OUTLINED IN THAT PLAN SO
THAT WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR US AS A- AS A FINER POINT
ON IT. AND HAVE A SLAM. YOUR A
PLAN THERE BENCHMARKS. ARE YOU
GONNA TO US YOUR REACHING THE
REACHING THE BAY. ARE ARE TO WE
HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT. BUT
WHAT. I TO GET A- COMMUTER. IN
THE TRAY. PLAN OKAY SO YOU TELL
IF YOU'RE NOT MEETING THE BEST
FRIEND. WHEN OUT. OF YES AND I
AM PICKING UP AROUND. FROM THE
COMMITTEE THAT AGE BE TAUGHT.
AS WELL. DETECTIVE YOUR-
SENATOR. YEAH A QUICK FOLLOW UP
ON AND YOUR I JUST A QUICK
FOLLOW UP ON CHERRY- QUESTION-
OKAY YOU'LL HAVE IT TRANSITION
PLAN FOR A IN LATE. OR ABLE TO
GET US ANY PREVIEW RIGHT NOW AS
TO WHERE YOU FEEL YOU'RE
MEETING YOUR BENCHMARKS AND
WE'RE- EASY CHALLENGES. YEAH I
THINK AGAIN YOU'RE HEARING IT
HERE FROM US- THAT THE-
SPECIFIC AREAS RELATED TO
REPORTING. AND FISCAL CLOSE OUT
OF THOSE CROSS IN SOME CASES AT
THE STATE FISCAL YEAR AND SOME
OF RUN A FEDERAL FISCAL CYCLE.
SO AGAIN WE ANTICIPATE BACK AT
THE CLOSING OF THE BOOKS IF YOU
WILL WILL OCCUR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING YOU KNOW A
COUPLE OF MONTHS REMAINING.
TRANSFERRING THAT JULY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT WOULD BE AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT WOULD OCCUR.
HOUSE JULY IN STAYED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. OTHER
CONTRACTING PEACE AGAIN WE WANT
THAT WORK ITS PRE WORK IF YOU
WILL AGAIN PRIOR TO THE
ENACTMENT OF THE BUDGET. IN
TERMS OF THE LANGUAGE CHANGES
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT'S
ACTUALLY BEING WORKED ON REAL
TIME WE WOULD OUTLINED. IN I
WOULD JUST SAY AGAIN THAT BEEN
FROM THE BEGINNING AND AGAIN
BASED ON ALL ENGAGE THAT WE'VE
HAD ACROSS. THE STATE ABOUT
COMMITMENT OF OURSTO
ABSOLUTELY AVOID ANY DISRUPTION
SERVICE WE GET RECOGNIZE ALL
THINGS CONSIDERED ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC HOW
CRITICAL. AT THIS SUPPORT IS
FOR FAMILY SO THAT IS THAT
PERSON FOR. OUR PRIORITY TO
ENSURE THAT SEAMLESS AND SMOOTH
AND- AND WE'RE ON TRACK TO DO
THAT SO. AGAIN THAT THE
EXAMPLES I GIVE YOU ARE ARE
RELATED TO HER REPORTING FISCAL
CLOSE OUT STARTING TODAY SO I
GUESS JUST A FOLLOW UP I MEAN.
YOU KNOW I THINK OF THIS ALMOST
LIKE AND IN A CONTEXT THERE'S
COUNTLESS EXAMPLES OF
CORPORATIONS THAT DECIDED BUY
ALLEN REQUIRE OR MERGE WITH
OTHER COMPANIES- ON PAPER IT
LOOKS GREAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
BLEND THEIR OPERATIONS. ON ON
THE BALLOT SHEETS. BUT THEIR
CHALLENGES AND I GUESS WHAT I'M
SEEING AND HEARING HERE IS THAT
YOU'RE EXPERIENCING A LOT OF
CHALLENGES- YOU KNOW IF WE LOOK
TO OUR BUSINESS SCHOOL
COUNTERPARTS- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT TYPICALLY GETS IDENTIFIED
AS A MAJOR OBSTACLE TO
SUCCESSFUL BLENDING OF
OPERATIONS IS. CULTURE AND I
GUESS I'D BE INTERESTED. IN
BOTH THE CITY AND CDSS.
DESCRIBING IF YOU THINK THEIR
CULTURAL DIFFERENCES BETWEEN.
THE TWO DEPARTMENTS THAT
PRESENT SOME CHALLENGES AS FAR
AS INTEGRATING. STAFF AND
OPERATIONS. SURE GLAD GLAD TO
ANSWER IS ONE SAFE USE. HERE IN
TURN ADDS THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT
FOR EDUCATION'S LONG STANDING
HISTORY OF WORKING TOGETHER ON
THESE PROGRAMS AS YOU HEARD. A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CHOI AND
MENTIONED THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES HAS BEEN
ADMINISTERING CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS. CALYXT H. ONE B.
EXAMPLE BUT SHE LISTED OTHERS
IN TERMS OF THE EMERGENCY CHILD
CARE BRIDGE. FOR FOSTER
FAMILIES ETCETERA BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN. COUNTLESS I WOULD
SAY. INTERAGENCY WORKGROUPS.
AND TO THE COURSE OF THIS CAN
AND SO OF THE REAL THAT BEEN
OUTLINED IN OUR TWO. THIS
MORNING I WE HAVE WORKED
TOGETHER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION ON THOSE IN AND AGAIN
WARNING TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
FAMILIES FOR EXAMPLE.
EXPERIENCING THE COW WORKS AT
THREE STAGES OF CHILD CARE ARE
THOSE SAME FAMILIES THAT WOULD
TO THE EXTENT THAT OUR POLICIES
ARE ALIGNED. TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT TIGHTENING OF
DELIVERABLES EXCEPT IRAQ AT
THOSE THINGS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER. ON FOR A VERY LONG
TIME AND HAVE THAT RELATIONSHIP
AND SO- CERTAINLY AGAIN THE
PRIORITIES THAT I OUTLINED AT
THE BEGINNING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT RELATED TO ADDRESS
INEQUITIES RELATED TO DATA
DRIVEN OUTCOMES. IN RELATED TO
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT I WOULD
SAY ARE SHARED ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENTS. TO GET A LOT OF
WORK HAS BEEN DONE IN THAT
SPACE OVER TIME TOGETHER- IT
ESPECIALLY IT LIFTED UP YOU'LL
SEE AGAIN I THINK THAT DETAIL.
OUTLINED IN SOME OF THE
APPROACHES THAT I WILL DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO ADDRESS RELATED
TO HOW THEY'LL ALSO BE EMBEDDED
IN THE STATE PRESCHOOL AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM SO I GUESS JUST A
FOLLOW UP TO REALLY QUICKLY I
MEAN. I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
WORK TOGETHER YOU HAVE A
COOPERATIVE RELATIONSHIP I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT WHICH IS IN I
DON'T I'VE NEVER STEPPED IN
YOUR OFFICES I. DON'T REALLY
KNOW HOW YOU OPERATE ON I'M
JUST CURIOUS ARE THEIR CULTURAL
DIFFERENCES. BETWEEN YOUR
DIFFERENT OFFICES- THAT MIGHT
PRESENT ANY KIND OF CHALLENGE
AND I THINK I'M HEARING YOU.
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT THE CASE
BUT I. MAY YOU COULD JUST
CLARIFY. YEAH AGAIN I WOULDN'T
SPEAK TO THE CULTURE OF THE
PART THAT I WILL DO. THAT TO
MICHAEL. AND I TERMS OF THE
WORK IN THE- IS THAT WE HAD ON.
A DRESS SYSTEM CHANGES I WE
HAVE DONE A LOT. AND SPACE
AGAINST GET CAN TO MAKE. AS
THEY GO. OTHER DEPARTMENTS
SOCIAL. THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAVE BEEN MEETING ON
A MONTHLY BASIS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION STAFF
WHO ARE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ENSURING THAT THE
QUESTIONS THAT THEY HAVE ARE
ADDRESSED AT THE UNDERSTAND
WHAT TO EXPECT. WHAT IS THEIR
DAY ONE LOOK LIKE. A HOW WILL
ANY KIND OF- SATELLITE THE
REGIONAL OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE THEIR LOCATION CHANGE
THAT WE HAVE MADE A- VERY
INTENTIONAL EFFORT TO ENGAGE
THE STAFF THAT ARE IMPACTED.
AND MAKE SURE THEIR QUESTIONS
ARE DRESSED IN IN ANDERSON WHAT.
TO EXPECT AS THE TRANSITION
OCCURS. DID YOU. JOHN RESPONSE
I'VE HAD IT MY BE HELPFUL.
SHARE THE COMMITTEE. AND THAT
IS A OF THOSE- MONTHLY IN. AND
THEN IT JUST WE DO ALSO SAY.
THE CD STAFF WOULD BE
TRANSITION OVER. THE OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- ABOUT THEIR HOPES AND
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRANSITION AND WHAT WE HEARD
BACK WAS THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF RESPONDENTS EXPRESSED EITHER
NEUTRAL. OR POSITIVE FEELINGS
ABOUT THE TRANSITION SO SIXTY
PERCENT. NEUTRAL AND 15% THAT
WERE POSITIVE. AND THE
REMAINING 25% HAD QUESTIONS. OR
CONCERNS AND IT WAS HELPFUL TO
US TO HEAR SOME MORE ABOUT
THAT. IN OUR ON GOING MONTHLY
ENGAGEMENT. FORUM AND IN THE
DAY TO DAY WORK GROUPS WE COULD
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THOSE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS FROM
THAT- SMALLER NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO HAPPEN. AND JUST AS A
FOLLOW. UP WHEN WAS A SURVEY
TAKEN. I IT WAS NOVEMBER TWO
TWENTY NOVEMBER OKAY. AND CITY.
THANK FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SOME
MORE SIMONET GO BACK ONE STEP
JUST TO SAY THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH CDSS ON SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ON ESPECIALLY THE CHALLENGES
AROUND PAYMENTS AND ENSURING
THE CLOTHES OUT AND
APPROPRIATIONS THEY WOULD BE IN
THE TRANSITION OVER NDSS THIS
PROJECT BUT SEAT BUT OBVIOUSLY
IF WE CONTINUE WITH PAYMENTS
WOULD NEED SOMETHING IN OUR
BUDGET AS WELL WE ALSO WOULDN'T
HAVE THE STAFF TO DO SOME OF
THE FEDERAL CLOSE OUT. YEAH ALL
THE STAFF TRANSITIONS AND THERE
ARE SOME NUANCES ARE LIKE THE
NITTY GRITTY COMPONENTS OF
WHERE STAFF ARE AND WHERE'S THE
FUNDING APPROPRIATION THAT DIVE
INTO THAT JULY TIME PERIOD THAT
YOU WE FLAGGED AS SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT MORE
CLOSELY THERE ARE ALSO SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT DATABASE
CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE MADE
ESPECIALLY AROUND THINGS LIKE
THE PAYMENTS AND IN REGARDS TO
THE CULTURE WE WOULD SAY JUST
ASK- WHAT CAN. ART DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND HIS TRAVIS I'D BOTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE VERY COMMITTED
TO SUPPORTING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES I THINK THERE'S A
SHARED PASSION AND COMMITMENT
TO THE FIELDS THERE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS OPERATED EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS SINCE
WORLD WAR TWO SO FAR OUR
CULTURE IT REALLY IS THAT FROM
BIRTH IT'S PART OF AN
EDUCATIONAL CONTINUE M. AND
WE'RE VERY FOCUSED ON EARLY ADD
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
NARROWING OR PREVENTING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. SO PEOPLE COME
AND BE COMMITTED TO EDUCATION
AS PART OF THE WAY IT IS IN SO
I WOULD SEE THE CITY CULTURE
THAT'S UNIQUE ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES IS THAT LESS PEOPLE
LEAVE THEY'RE DRAWN TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR SPECIFIC REASON
AND THERE'S LESS BOUNCING
AROUND TO GET SPECIFIC JOB
COMPONENTS THEY HAVE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL AND MASTERS IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT OR EARLY EDUCATION
AND- ARE COMMITTED TO INCLUSION
SPECIAL EDUCATION. EDUCATION
FROM BIRTH THOSE OPPONENTS
REALLY ARE CORE OF OUR CULTURE.
THAT'S A GREAT SEGUE TO MY NEXT
COURT ACTUALLY I WONDERING IF
YOU SPEAK TO THEM. OF SOME OF
THE E. D. S. C. C. FOLK THAT
WERE- TASK THIS THAT BE TRAINS.
OF WE HAVE THIS SURVEY FROM
NOVEMBER DESCENT SORT OF MATCH
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING WITH FOLKS
I MEAN THEY'RE THEY'VE GOT
OBVIOUSLY HUGE WORKLOAD- WE'RE
DEALING WITH KOBE IT'S SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A TOUGH TIME.
IS IMPORTANT IS MORALE IN YOUR
VIEW HIGH AMONG THESE EMPLOYEES
RIGHT NOW. I WOULD SAY OVERALL
FOR STATE EMPLOYEES IT'S
PROBABLY PRETTY LOW. THEY HAVE
THE ALMOST 10% PAY CUT ON TOP
OF ALL THAT JUST NOT PANDEMIC
WORK. AND YOU'VE HEARD FAMILY
LAW SAYS AND OTHER COMPONENTS
HAVE BEEN THESE LOSING JOBS OR
FROM THEM AND TO MAKE IT SO. SO
I WOULD STAY. THEY'RE JUST
DESERVE OVERALLS MORALE ISSUES.
IN REGARDS TO THIS TRANSITION
SPECIFICALLY WE'VE HAD SOME
STATS SAY THAT THEY'RE LEANING
AND ESPECIALLY FROM THE
ANALYSTS LEVEL BECAUSE THEY DO
SEE POTENTIAL PROMOTIONS. THE
ONES WHO ARE MORE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CONSULTANTS-
EDUCATION PROGRAM CONSULTANTS.
WE'VE HEARD MORE CONCERNS FROM
AROUND. SEVEN WE NOW THERE ARE
SOME STAFF WHO THINK. RATE THIS
IS A TIME IN WHICH MASS THAT A
KID OF OUR FAMILY AND SO WILL
REALLY BE A- ACROSS REGIONS.
AND BUT WE DO KNOW AND HAVE
ALERTED YES THAT'S THAT THERE
ARE SOME STAFF OR LOOKING FOR
OTHER JOBS SAID THERE. THERE
WILL BE SOME STAFF WHO DON'T
WANT TO LIVE IN THE CITY AND
BECAUSE OF THAT WILL REALLY
LOOKS TOWARDS CD AND FINDING A
DIFFERENT POSITION. THANK I HAD
A DIFFERENT COURT.
INDETERMINATE ARE TO BE TOLD
RESPECTFUL OF SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS BUT- WE HAVE A
COMPLETE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
TO COME AFTER THIS AND THE
PUBLIC COMMENT ONE MORE PANEL
SO. YOU GO AHEAD AND ASK IT I
HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION AND THEN
THEN MAYBE THE ANSWER COULD BE
BRIEF YEAH- SO. YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS IS FOR C. D. E. YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT. YOU BECAUSE WE
STILL WOULD MAINTAIN CONTROL
OVER A LOT OF THE CHILD CARE.
THROUGH YOUR CONTROLLER
PRESCHOOLS AS WONDERING- IS
JUST PRETTY COMMON OR ARE THERE
CAN BE A LOT OF AREAS WHERE
THERE'S OVERLAPPING AUTHORITY
BETWEEN YOU AND- DSS. THE
CURRENTLY SOME. BETWEEN STAGE
ONE AND THE REST OF THAT CAL
WORK STAGES. BUT NOT NEARLY AS
MUCH AND SINCE THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES OPERATE
STAGE ONE THREE THE COUNTY
WELFARE DEPARTMENTS AND WE USE
THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS TO OPERATE AT CENTER
WITH SAYS TRANSACTION THERE
WILL BE SIGNIFICANT OVERLAP
BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR
CONTRACTORS THAT ARE.
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM CONTRACTORS ALSO HOLD
EITHER EARLY LEARNING CARE
CONTRACTS AND THE SAME WITH THE
NUTRITION PROGRAMS SAID THEY
MIGHT HOLD A CHILD AND ADULT
CARE FOOD PROGRAM BUT ALSO HAVE
ONE OF OUR OTHER SCHOOL BASED
MEAL PROGRAMS. THAT WE OPERATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TRAILER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THEN LET ME JUST IN
SUMMARY SAY TO THE PEOPLE THAT
TESTIFIED YOU PICKED UP. THE
CONCERN OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
WE WANT TO KNOW THAT THIS
TRANSITION IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
HAPPEN ON TIME IT THAT IF IT'S
NOT THAT YOU FLY GUESTS. IN A
TIMELY AND APPROPRIATE MANNER
ABOUT WHAT THE ISSUES ARE THE
REMAINING AND- AND I JUST
PICKED THAT UP FROM EVERYBODY
STATEMENTS AND QUESTIONS WILL
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
WHICH IS AN OVERVIEW OF THE
MASTER PLAN IT'S GOING TO BEGIN
WITH CHRIS PERRY FROM HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES JOURNAL
KUBRICK FROM- WEST DEAD AND
THEN SIR CORTEZ FROM THE LA O'S
OFFICE IN WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER. WELCOME MISTER. THANK
YOU CHAIR. HAPPY TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
WE HAVE REDUCED THE LENGTH OF
THE PRESENTATION. AND WOULD
DIRECT YOU TO OUR HANDOUTS FOR
THE DETAILS BUT I WOULD ALSO
REALLY LIKE TO THANK YOU AND
THE LEGISLATURE FOR. THE
SUPPORT IN THE LEADERSHIP ON
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE OVER
MANY MANY YEARS AND THE
SUPPORT- ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE MASTER PLAN. WE THINK THAT
THE TITULAR LAY IN A- COMA
NINETEEN HAND EMIC WORLD- AND
THE FRAGILITY THAT'S BEEN
EXPOSED IN THE EARLY LEARNING
SYSTEM THAT THE MASTER PLAN. IS
WELL TIMED AND I THINK WILL
PROVIDE US WITH SOME OPTIONS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
INCREASING ACCESS TO QUALITY
CARE. FOR CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
MORE SUPPORT FOR THE WORK FORCE
WITHOUT ALTERNATE NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW COULD
CONNECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU CHRIS FOR
THAT INTRODUCTION I'M GONNA
SHARE MY SCREEN. HERE- WE.
THIRD DISTRICT- BUILT ON MY
CHRISTMAS AND WANTED TO GIVE
YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
MASTER PLAN I IN YOUR ITEMS
ONLINE THAT AGE TWENTY TWO
YEARS AB IT OUTLINED IN TERMS
OF HOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
AND REALLY IT'S A LONG TERM
PLAN- LOOKING FORWARD AND
SAYING IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
WORKING TOWARDS TRANSFORMING
EARLY CARE AND LEARNING SYSTEM.
HI AND THIS INCLUDES BUILDING
AROUND FOUR KEY COMPONENTS
AROUND AS CHRIS MENTIONED
ACCESS AND QUALITY AND SCHOOL
READING AS SPEND AND ALSO
LOOKING AT THAT WORKSHOPS AND
HOW WE BUILD FOR THAT. FUTURE-
WE HAVE PUT EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
IN A- CREDIT REPORT WHICH CAN
BE DOWNLOADED AT THE PROJECT'S
WEBSITE. BOB WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS WEBSITE IN
THAT IT BRINGS TO LIFE THE
THINGS THAT WE FOUND THROUGH
THE RESEARCH ON THIS PROJECT-
AND THAT IS IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE
IT'S ABOUT CHILDREN IT'S ABOUT
THEIR FAMILIES AND ABOUT THOSE
THAT. CARE AND EDUCATE OUR
YOUNG CHILDREN AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THIS WEBSITE
IS- BROUGHT THE REPORT AS WELL
AS A SUMMARY BUT YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THOSE STORIES YOUR VIDEOS.
AS WELL AS A WAY THAT JUST THE-
REALLY KEY POINTS AROUND HOW
ARE WE SUPPORTING IN A COUPLE
SYSTEM HOW ARE WE TRANSFORMING
WHAT WE DO. AND PROVIDE AND
SUPPORT AND MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE COME OUT THROUGHOUT
THIS HEARING WHICH REGARD TO.
ON HOW WE MAKING SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN WITH THE GREATEST
NEEDS ARE SERVED. HOW DO WE
FUND THE SYSTEM HOW DO WE
SUPPORT THE WORKFORCE I'M
ALREADY DRESSED IN IN THE PLANS
AND IDEAS SHARED IN THE REPORT
AND- I CONNECTED TO WHAT'S-
AVAILABLE TO THE WEBSITE. TO
VERY BRIEFLY AGAIN I KNOW THIS
IS IN THERE I. DON'T KNOW IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE TWENTY FOUR-
THERE THERE ARE THESE REC. ARE
KEY GOAL AREAS ARE. AND GONNA
HIGHLIGHTED FEW FOR YOU- IN AND
WHAT I SHOULD SO. FOUR KEY
AREAS- PROGRAM WORKFORCE.
GOVERNANCE IMAGE. AND BASICALLY
THE UNDERLINING FOCUS OF THE
MASTER PLAN IS HOW DO WE
PROVIDE FOR THE TREMENDOUS NEED
THAT EXISTS FOR YOUNG CHILDREN.
BETTER STATE BASED ON RESEARCH
OF WHAT WE KNOW MAKES A
DIFFERENCE FOR THEIR OUTCOMES.
ON FOR THEIR LIVES AND SO
INTERCONNECTED IN ALL OF THIS
IS HAVING PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
FOR SUPPORT NEEDS. ARE WE
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT AREAS
SUCH AS PAID FAMILY LEAVE-
INTEGRATION WITH. LOOKING AT
YOURS ARE ZERO THREE THREE
SYSTEM AND THE PRESCHOOL. AND
WHAT IT MEANS TO EXPAND ACCESS
WHAT IT MEANS TO ENRICH
OPPORTUNITIES. AND PUTTING THAT
TOGETHER IN A FRAMEWORK THAT.
SUPPORTS CONTINUITY OF CARE
SUPPORTS EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN IN
ADDRESSING THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF
OUR STATE. ON ALL OF THIS
THOUGH IS NOT POSSIBLE UNLESS
WE HAVE PEOPLE READY TO PROVIDE
FOR THAT CARE AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY. AND TO WORKING
TOWARDS BUILDING OUR WORKFORCE
BASED ON WITH THE SKILLS THE
COMPETENCIES. IN THE PATHWAYS
FOR CAREER THAT WILL LEAD TO US
BEING ABLE TO EXPAND AND
ADDRESS- THE KIND OF
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS WE SEE FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN. AND THEN.
IMPORTANTLY AND WE'VE HEARD
THIS COME OUT THROUGHOUT THE
SITE HEARING IS HOW DO WE PUT
TOGETHER A FUNDING SYSTEM. SO
THAT. ARE IT'S BOTH ADDRESSING
THE NEEDS BUT ALSO. CREATING
ALIGNMENT WHAT WE SAY IT
MATTERS IN THE SYSTEM SO- YOU
KNOW SUPPORTING IT WAS CALLED
OUT THE DIFFERENCES WE ARE
RIGHT SO WE PUT TOGETHER. A SET
OF RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
HOW TO LOOK AT RATES AND
RESTRUCTURING THEM- SO THAT
WERE UNIFIED IN OUR SYSTEM TO
FIND THAT WE DON'T SEE THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW. THAT LEADER OSEI
UNEVENNESS IN THE WAY THAT OUR
PROGRAMS ARE EXPERIENCED- OR
ARE. UTILIZED IN THE SEARCH
SOME SORT OF LOOK FOR A TO AS
WE CAN. THE FUNDS- ALTER IN
ENTRY. THE WAY THEY WE PROVIDE
PROGRAM. TO CREATE A- TO
SUPPORT PATH. AND ALTERNATELY
PRO ARE- WHAT WE SEE. MATTERS
FROM RESEARCH WITH REGARD TO
QUALITY AND- BUILDING FOR FOUR
EIGHT A FUTURE THAT IS MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE IN OUR
PROGRAMS AND THEN FINALLY.
LOOKING AT GOVERNANCE
ADMINISTRATION SAID THIS GETS
TO YOU. HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE MANAGE THESE PROGRAMS
THEY'RE DONE IN THE BEST
POSSIBLE WAY- THAT STREAMLINES
THAT THEY DIED TAKES ADVANTAGE
OF. VARIOUS TOOLS IT WAS CALLED
EARLIER IN THE HEARING WHERE WE
HAD DATA WHERE WE PUT TOGETHER
NETWORKS WHERE WE- LOOK FOR
THOSE TYPES OF. OPPORTUNITIES
TO- SUPPORT EQUITY THROUGH- OUR
AGENCY AND EXPERIENCE THAT-
REALLY IS PARENT FRIENDLY
FAMILY FRIENDLY- IN TERMS OF
THEIR INTERACTION OF
NAVIGATING. FOR THEIR NEEDS SO
THE REPORT GOES INTO GREAT
DETAILS REGARDING SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES INCLUDING- YOU KNOW
EXPANSION OF PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE FUNDING FORMULAS
INCLUDING LOOKING AT STRUCTURES
FOR THE WORK FORCE- AND BREAKS
THIS DOWN. INTO ACTION STEPS
THAT INVOLVED- ALL OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES WORKING TOGETHER
CONTRIBUTING BUT ALSO- LOOKING
TO OUR YOU KNOW OUR OUR
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES ARE
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITIES AND-
ALTERNATELY ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
FAMILIES SO- PART. OF THE
CHARGE OF THIS. REPORTER
RESEARCH WAS TO LOOK AND SAY
WOW WHAT IT. AND WHAT WE THAT
INCLUDE- IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
R. CHANGES TO THE SYSTEM AND SO
WE HAVE OUTLINED IN OUR WORK-
AND CREATED A COST DRIVEN
MODEL. THAT DEPENDED UPON THE
KINDS OF POLICIES AND- AND
CHOICES THAT ARE MADE- WOULD
LEAD TO ANYWHERE BETWEEN OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS ANOTHER
ADDITIONAL TWO TO TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT
AND SO- PRESENTLY. WE HAVE
ABOUT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
CURRENT- PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SYSTEM BY IN ADDITION THERE'S
ANOTHER APPROXIMATELY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IT'S
CONTRIBUTED THROUGH FAMILY FEES
FOR VARIOUS TYPES OF SUPPORT.
AND SO ESSENTIALLY WE'RE
SAYING- UPWARDS OF DOUBLING IN
THE NEXT TEN YEARS WOULD BE ON
ON ORDER OF CREATING THE KIND
OF ACCESS ADDRESSING THE
QUALITY- AND BUILDING A SYSTEM.
THAT WE THINK REALLY WILL
FOLLOW WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS WE
SEE IN THE RESEARCH- WITH
REGARD TO THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN. IN SUPPORT OF THOSE
THAT THAT ARE CARING AND
EDUCATING THEM- SO I WANT TO
LEAVE TIME FOR YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND HAPPY TO GO INTO
ANY FURTHER DETAILS ABOUT
WHAT'S IN THE PLAN I'M LIKE I
SAID YOU HAVE A BIT MORE IN THE
ITEM. PRICE TWO D. BETWEEN THAT
AND WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE- YOU
TO CHECK OUT THE. REPORT-
THROUGH THE WEBSITE. AND THEN
THE L. A. MY SERRA PRETEND LIKE
TO AND OFFICE WELL MY FELLOW
PANELISTS WERE KEY INDIVIDUALS
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF DRAFTING
OF THE MASTER PLAN I JOIN THE
PANEL TODAY AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
READ THE MASTER PLAN CONTAINED
IN DOCUMENTS AND ATTENDED
ASSOCIATED BRIEFINGS SO WHILE
THE LEGISLATURE WAS NOT
INVOLVED IN ANY OF THE RESEARCH
EFFORTS OR DRAFTING OF THE
MASTER PLAN. THE LEGISLATURE
WAS ABLE TO SCOPE THE RESEARCH
QUESTION THROUGH THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL PROCESS TO THIS
END THE LEGISLATURE COULD
EVALUATE WHETHER THE MASTER
PLAN ANSWERED ALL THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED QUESTIONS
AND OTHER QUESTIONS OF INTEREST
WE WHICH IS KNOWN FOR THE
COMMITTEE THAT WHILE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PLAN READ
SHE WAS PART OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
AGREEMENT THE IMPLEMENTED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MASTER
PLAN HAS NOT YET BEEN AGREED TO
BY THE LEGISLATURE. AS THE
ADMINISTRATION PRESENTS FOR
POSTAL THAT STEM FROM THE
MASTER PLAN WORKS SUCH AS THE
TEACHING EXPANSION PROPOSAL THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARD LAST WEEK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ME WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THESE ACTIONS MAINTAIN
ALIGNMENT WITH ITS PRIORITIES
WE WOULD NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH THE
MASTER PLANS ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL
THERE ARE A LOT OF OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS THE STATE WOULD NEED
TO ADDRESS TO IMPLEMENT THE
MASTER PLAN. AND MOST NOTABLY
THE FISCAL PICTURE ON THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT I'M
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS. OF THE
COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. CENTER PAN. SO
PRETTY WE HAVE THE MASTERPIECE-
OLD IS THE INDUSTRY RECOGNIZE
RIVER SHORT AMOUNT TIME HERE
TODAY HEY YES- DAHLE NEED
DETAILS OF THE PLANET RIGHT NOW
BUT WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ESSENTIALLY.
PRESENT THE PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND- PRIORITIZE HOW
WERE DOUBTS GOING INTO GREAT
WITH THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
TERMS OF EXECUTING THIS PLAN-
ONCE WE GET- AGREEMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. HE JUST BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON THAT EXPLAIN WHAT THAT
THE PROPOSAL THE PLAN FOR THE-
DEMONSTRATIONS PLANNED TO DO SO.
MS BERRY I THINK THAT'S TO YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- AS MENTIONED BY
THE L. A. O. THE THERE ARE A
FEW RECOMMENDATIONS ALREADY
BEING CONSIDERED AS PART OF
THIS BUDGET CYCLE SUCH AS E. T.
K. EXPANSION AND I BELIEVE
EARLIER IN THE MORNING WHEN YOU
HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW.
BEST TO USETHE FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR RECOVERY- THOSE ARE
SOMEWHAT ALIGNED WITH SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
MASTER PLAN SLOW WE ARE ALREADY
SEEING SOME ALIGNMENT WITH
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AND WILL.
PARTNER WITH- OUR COLLEAGUES AT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND CD IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON CREATIVE WAYS OF
IMPLEMENTING PARTS OF THE
MASTER PLAN IN THE NEAR TERM
BUT THIS IS A TEN YEAR PLAN. IT
WILL TAKE MANY YEARS- AND WE
CAN START SOME OF THE WORK WITH
THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WERE
RECEIVING NOW. OKAY I GUESS I
WOULD JUST SAY AS I'VE BEEN
HERE OTHER THAN TO HEARING THAT
THERE'S BITS OF THE PLAN BEING
TUCKED INTO THE BUDGET SOME OF
IT BASED ON FEDERAL FUNDS WHICH
OF COURSE ARE NOT. ONGOING
BECAUSE IF THIS WERE TALKING
CODE FUNDS THOSE ARE TEMPORARY-
I GUESS I WOULD URGE THAT THERE
BE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
APPROPRIATE- BOTH POLICY AND-
SUBCOMMITTEE. BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES IN TERMS OF-
PRESENTING THE PLAN MORE AS A
WHOLE AND THEN COMING UP WITH A
STRATEGY I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THIS IS GONNA BE BUILT INTO THE
MULTI YEAR PROJECTIONS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FINANCING NO WE
PASS. A YEAR'S BUDGET TIME BUT
OFTENTIMES MULTI YEAR
PROJECTIONS SO. THAT THAT'S
PART. WILL BE SEEING THAT IN
THE MULTI YEAR PROJECTIONS THE
BUDGET STRUCTURE AND-
GOVERNORS- PROPOSAL WE COME TO
MAY. BUT I THINK- SOME GREATER
CLARITY AS FAR AS HOW THIS PLAN
IS GOING TO BE PRESENTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE
APPRECIATED. BOB LET ME JUST
REITERATE CENTER PANTS CONCERN
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE- RUNNING
LATE TODAY NEW SHOULDN'T
CONCERN A CONFUSED THE FACT
THAT WE'RE NOT ASKING LOTS OF
QUESTIONS AND MAKING LOTS O
STATEMENTS. WITH A LACK OF
INTEREST I THINK WE ALIGN WITH
SENATOR PAN'S COMMENTS AND WE
WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THAT IS EVIDENT TO THE
STAFF. ARE GOING FORWARD AND IS
AVAILABLE FOR WHEN WE ACTUALLY
MAKE DECISIONS IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE.
AND THEN SITTING. HOURS THE-
AND WILL NOW. TO THE UPPER. TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SENATE'S PUBLIC COMMENT ON WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR. IN A MOMENT WE WILL GO TO.
A TELECONFERENCE SAYING SERVICE
FOR ANYBODY MAKING A COMMENT.
TELEPHONICALLY AND LET ME
REPEAT. THAT TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. 1-116-358-8442 NINE
ONE SIX THREE FIVE EIGHT. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE
ZERO. 407-465-0407 FOUR. BUT
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS. OF TIME
CONSTRAINTS IN THE HEARING.
BERMAN LIMIT PEOPLE'S COMMENTS
TO ONE MINUTE- THE MAINTAIN
DECORUM. AS I EXPRESSED
EARLIER. ARE NOW WHAT'S BEGIN.
WITH ANY WITNESSES THAT WE HAVE
IN THE HEARING ROOM IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THAT WISHES TO MAKE A COMMENT.
APPARENTLY THE SERGEANTS HAS
NOT MOVED TO MAKE A COMMENT SO
WE HAVE NOBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WANTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT IS THERE ANYBODY IN A
ROOM ONE TWELVE STEP WISHES TO
MAKE A COMMENT. SEEING NO ONE
STEPPING TO THE PODIUM THERE.
WE WILL MOVE TO OUR TELEPHONE
SYSTEM OF MODERATOR- IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WELL WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- LEASING
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO KILL
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. YOU MAY WITHDRAW YOUR
PROBLEM CAN QUEUE BY REPEATING
THE ONE ZERO COMMAND. IF YOU
ARE USING A SPEAKER PHONE WE
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN THE PLACE
YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SIX LINE THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
THIRTY SIX AGAIN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE
DISCONNECTED FROM THE CALL WILL
MOVE ALONG TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY NINE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
GETTING COLDER REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM AFFECT STATE AND- ON
BEHALF OF THE TRAINING DEBATE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE NONPROFIT
BUT A THIRD ARM. AT WORK IN
FACT THE DATA. AND EVENTUAL
WORKERS TO CHILDCARE WERE
GREATLY CONCERNED THAT I WAS.
ACTUALLY ELIMINATES OVER EIGHTY
SIX HUNDRED CHILD CARE ABOUT
YOUR SLOT. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE NUMBERS REFLECT THE
LAMINATING ONE TIME BUNKER
CENTRAL WORKERS. I THINK
THAT'S- WHAT IT BURKE. AT THE
BLAST BUT DEPRIVE. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO CHILDREN HAD NO
ACCESS TO CARE. WITH OVER A
MILLION IN NEED AND NOW WITH
THE- WE ARE SEEING MORE. I BY
U. P. S. THANK. NEEDING
CHILDCARE AND THERE IS WE CAN
DO THE PROPOSED BUDGET FUNDS
YOUR THAN SIX SEVEN THOUSAND
PLOT. IN REGARDS HEALTHCARE
RATE EITHER TO REIMBURSE BASED
ON TWENTY. ARM DATA WHEN THE
STATE WAGE WOULD NOT DOLLARS
TODAY THE MINIMUM WAGE AT
FOURTEEN GET FAMILY TRAFFIC
HERE PROVIDE. HAVE RECEIVED
WRITTEN CREATE THAT I REMEMBER
FOR A PROVIDER PROVIDING CARE
TO INFANT BETWEEN THREE TO AND
NINE HOUR. CALIFORNIA'S LAST
OVERVIEW YOU'VE GONE OVER ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS WE APPRECIATED
MODERATOR. WILL YOU QUEUE UP
THE NEXT CALLER. WELL NOW ONE
NUMBER FORTY NINE LINES NINE
LINE IS A. ONE FORTY LINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEARING A
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ALONG TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR LINE
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI- MY NAME IS MARIA LOVE
STORY. I'M WITH THE VOICE
SERVICE AND- I WOULD WITH A LOT
OF PARENTS- MEETING CHILD. AND
WE'RE GOING TO CANCEL THAT A
LOT OF OTHER CHARACTERS AND
FAMILY UNDER- SO THEIR DOORS.
AND WE REALLY WANT TO GET TO.
FORTY OUR PROVIDER BURKE THANK
YOU THERE DOES OPEN- WE ALSO.
CAUGHT THEY SPEND- S. BOY
SERVICE ASK THE IT STANDS. IS
GOING TO BRING THAT MAKE
CERTAIN BILLOWING DURING THE-
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILY TO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MUCH
NEXT CALLER. ALKALINE NUMBERS
SIX SIX RELY IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS A MERRY NATION WITH A PARENT
VOICES AS WELL- I JUST WANT TO
HOLDEN ON THE FACE THAT. WE
HAVE HIS. AND WOEFULLY UNDER.
OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM PROJECT.
AND WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
WITH REAL. BUT IT'S A TO
SUPPLEMENT NOT DOLLARS AND HOW
CAN WE STOP DAHLE THE WHEN THE
HAS NOT OFFERED ANY MONEY FOR
ONGOING CHOI CARE FOR DURING
AND WILL. BEING THE RESULT OF
THAT UNDER. AND WE TO THE LEAD.
WILL. WHAT IN THE MONEY THAT IS
NEEDED TO A THE CRY WE ARE
FACING TODAY- WE ARE ALSO FOR
THE LEGEND TO LOOK AT THE ME
RELIEF PACKAGE TO ALL INCLUDE.
OF THE FAN FEEDS FOUND WHO- ARE
YOU TERROR NOW WE ARE STUCK.
OUR TRIAL CARE SYSTEM THERE BY
BUT THE TWO SIXTY SO HOW
MILLION DOLLARS A- THAT IS
MONEY THAT IS THE TRUE IN THE
BY- TIME. BUT IT MEANS YOU KNOW
KEEP UP WITH YOUR YOU TO PAYING
YOUR GETTING GAS IS THE REAL OF
THANK YOU VERY FOR YOUR- LIKE
TO GO A LITTLE BIT OVER A ONE
MINUTE. OF MODERATOR NEXT CALL
COMES COLOR. SIX PUBLIC COMMENT
BECAUSE NUMBER SEVENTY SIX SIX
YOUR LINE IS A- THANK GOOD
MORNING CAN LIVE REPRESENTING.
NOW AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE MEMBERS QUESTIONED
ACCORDING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE CURRENT PROJECTS AND
GHOSTFACE SAYS. BUT THE NEED
WILL BE IN FACT FOR CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND FUNDAMENTAL ANALLY
HOW TO STABILIZE THE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. INCLUDING PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND UPDATING THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES. RIGHT AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE MAKERS TO PERCEIVE
THE MANY OF THE STRATEGIES THAT
WERE DISCUSSED TODAY AT THE
WAITING FAMILY. HOLDING TOUCH
PROGRAM ARE MY PRETENDING YOUR
FIRST AND WORKER THE HELL
PROVIDE. A BRIGHTER FAMILY BUT
A PANDEMIC IN ADDITION WE
SUPPORT PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
ONGOING FUNDING OUR MAR. I'M
PUTTING FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR IN THAT DAY AND
REIMBURSEMENT RATES UP TO THAT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARMAR SERVING
LEVEL. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE THE
TRANSITION OF TOUCH YOUR
PROGRAMS OF PDF AFTER PRECIADO
ROBOT THAT COLDER PROCESS. THEY
HAVE PUT IN PLACE TO WITH FIELD
PART OF THE INTER. AND WE
REMAIN. THAT THE TRANSITIONAL
SUPPORT OF STRONGER MORE
COHESIVE. WITH THEM FOR ABOUT
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS LONG RUN.
AND LASTLY WE BERKELEY THAT
NOTICE TRICKS ACT TO CALIFORNIA
FOR YEAR OLD WHERE'S ABOUT THE
DIRE. NEED FOR MORE AND PUBLIC
HEARING. AS A FEW AT AND UP
INTO AND ARE BEING THIRD- GOING
TO GO MUCH I LECTURE GOOD OVER.
HER COMMENTS VERY MUCH MORE NAY
BECAUSE. NEXT WILL COME FROM
NUMBER TWO EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
A. KATHY WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE JUST AS- A FEW QUICK
HOME ON THE END OF EITHER ON
THE IN. BERSERKER THE
TRANSITION OF CARE PRO TO CDS
THAT COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENT ARE PER. IN THE MEETING
THAT THIS IS PROPERTY IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT OUR FAMILY
RECEIVE CONTINUITY CARE AT THE
TREND IS OF KERR AND WE HAVE
THOSE MEETING BEING MADE
AVAILABLE. REGARDING THE MASTER
PLAN WE BELIEVE THE PLANET
GREAT TO BETTER CORD OF
PROGRAMS AND- ACROSS THE EARLY
LEARNING SPECTRUM COMPREHENSIVE
REPORT AMATEUR. WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE EARLY
CHARACTERS READINESS
CALIFORNIA'S. CHILDREN WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT YOU DO WANT TO
SHE'LL THANK WORKING SHOULD BE
A- BY THE COUNTY HUMAN SERVICE
EACH YEAR. PART OF CAL WORK.
SURE TO LIVE STREAM I
ADMINISTRATION OF THE HOURS
BURKE. THANKS COUNTY FOR WITH
HER TO WORKS INSURANCE THEY CAN
FOR A VARIETY OF. COURT AND IT
IS TO CHILD CARE IS PART OF
THEIR WELCOME TO WORK PRETTY.
HOUSING ARE NOW CDF FROM THEIR
ENTIRE. WILL ALLOW US TO DO SO
IN THE EVEN MORE EXTREME WAY
BUT KEEPING THE OFFERING.
FLETCHER GO A BIT OVER RECOUNTS
MINUTE THANK YOU MUCH YOUR-
MODERATOR NEXT. WELL THAT WOULD
ALIGN NUMBERS SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINER OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS A BUT AND I'M EXACT
DIRECTOR OF THE- FOUND ALL. ON
BEHALF OF THE THIRD STYLE AND
FIVE THE APPEARANCE. ACROSS THE-
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY
THAT WE HAVE GROWING AND THE
YARD FOR THE- TO YES THAT WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO OUT THAT
DURING THE- IN OUR- COME. ABOUT
THE CONCERNS FEARS THAT THE AND
THE LONG TERM GROWTH THE
PROGRAM. RESHAPING THE
OFFENSIVE FOCUS EQUITY AND
CHILD WILL BE IN THE- BECAUSE
IT HAVE A WHOLE APPROACH
WITHOUT. THE NUTRITION NEEDS.
CRITICAL TO THE TO THE- OF
YOUNG PEOPLE. WE LOOKED. TO THE-
AND BRIEF INTO THE EASIER.
PATTERSON AND- WITH EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAM BY. AND HELP
YOU MISTER. UNFORTUNATELY THE
THING FOCUS. ON THE IMPORTANCE
YOUR TRADE AND THE OF TIME CARE
EARLY LAW. AND SUPPORTING THEM.
NEEDS OF YOUNG CHILDREN WITH
ENTIRE LEFT OF THE MATH PLAN.
WHICH WE WOULD ARGUE WITH
MAJOR- OVERSIGHT BASICALLY OF.
IN THE CHILDREN. SO WHILE WE'RE-
OF THE TRANSIT OF. PETER AT
THAT. IS BEING. BY DEPARTMENT
WE WOULD A SLOWDOWN THE TRYING
TO INTO THE CAN. AND THEN
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
THAT WITH THE DRAMATIC AND IN
THE SECURE AND I'M SORRY YOU'VE
GONE A BIT- OVER HOW IT BEHIND
BITCOIN TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND ASKED THE- FOR THE
NEW. SPEAK. SPEAKERS LINE
NUMBERS THREE. THIRTY THREE
YEAR IS OPEN. I MEAN IT'S
MAKING. AND THE FORMER YOUTH
AND FOR OR COUNTY QUINCY OUR
SYSTEM. YEAH HELLO. ALSO A
SINGLE MOTHER DURING MY
TRAINING EDUCATION YEAH I'M NOT
HOW MUCH STABLE. EIGHT OUT AT
REALLY HELPFUL. HM IT WOULD
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE BEING ABLE
TO NOT A COMPLETE MAGIC BUT-
NOW. THE OTHER FORMER YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
COMMENT MODERATOR BEAKER. NEXT
WE WILL COMPLY NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING- THIS IS
PATCHWORK HERE THIRTY NATION
FIGHT CRIME INVESTING KIDS.
WHICH IS MADE UP OF LOCAL
BUSINESSES EXECUTIVES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPECTIVELY. IN
TWO RECENT ANALYSIS BY READING
NATION THE LACK OF RELIABLE
CHILDCARE FOR WORKING PARENTS
OF YOUNG CHILDREN COST YOU
ANYWHERE SIX ONE EIGHTY NINE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR IN LOST EARNINGS
PRODUCTIVITY AND REVENUE- THIS
ISSUE THE ONLY DISCOUNTS ARE
KANEMI BUT ALSO BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE AS WELL. IF
I POLICE CHIEF ABDUL PRIDGEN
WHO THE NEW PARENTS ONE EIGHT
MONTH OLD SAID WHEN WE SUPPORT
WHAT WORKS FOR DISADVANTAGED
CHILDREN WE PUT THEM IN OUR
COUNTRY ON A SAFER PASSED I
QUALITY CHILDCARE IS INTEGRAL
TO THE INSURING OUR KIDS GET
THE BEST ARE POSSIBLE. WE'RE
CALLING ON YOU TODAY TO SUPPORT
THE CONGRESS BECAUSE OF TWENTY
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY FOUR MILLION
AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED ADDITIONAL A. P.
SPOTS ABOUT YOUR PROPERTY-
SIXTY FOUR REVENUE.
MILITARISTIC THE CORTICAL
INCREASE FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN ORDER TO RETAIN
THESE AMAZING STAFFERS. THANK
YOU. YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR TIME-
MONTEREY NEXT. NEXT VEHICLE
COMES LINE NUMBER. THREE TO
YOUR IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS LAURIE HALDERMAN AND I
AM A PROGRAM MANAGER EARLY
CHILDHOOD FROM KAFKA OF LOS
ANGELES. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROPOSAL. TO EXTEND THE
INFANT COMPLEMENT. PRENATAL
BENEFIT SUPPLEMENT HAS HELPED
EXPECTING YOU BUT NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOSTER CARE PREPARE FOR
THE ARRIVAL OF THEIR NEWBORN
EXPECT YOU'D HAVE USED ON YOUR
PURCHASE CAR SEAT. BASSINET
RIGHT WIPES I KITS IN CLOTHING
AS WELL AS CLOTHING. THIS
BENEFIT HELPS FOSTER YOU
PREPARE FOR ARRIVAL THEIR YOUNG
CHILD AND ENSURE THAT YOUNG
CHIU HAS BASIC FOR STATE BE
CLOSE TRANSPORTATION
OPPORTUNITIES AND HYGIENE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MUCH. STE
MODERATOR NAY CALL. NEXT CALLER
SO MY NUMBER FIFTY FIVE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PINE FIFTY
CAN YOU CHECK YOUR LINE FOR
SELF MUTE WE'RE HEARING AUDIO.
NO RESPONSE I'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN NEXT SIX
SEVEN. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO SEE
CPU- AND R. FORTY THOUSAND
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
REPRESENTED BY SEIU CALIFORNIA
AND ASKED ME TO W. I WANT TO
SPEAK TODAY ON A COUPLE OF
THINGS RELATED TO STIMULUS FINE
CCP'S PROVIDE PROVIDERS ARE
HAPPY TO GET THAT- AN AGREEMENT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ADDRESS THE URGENT NEEDS TO
KEEP. TRACK OF YOUR OPENS THE
TYPICALLY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR PROVIDERS DEALING WITH
INCREASED COSTS AND ADDING PAY
CULTURE DAYS OF THE PROVIDERS
ARE ABLE TO RE OPEN AFTER
CORPORATE EXPOSURES- PART OF
THIS AGREEMENT AS YOU GUYS KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE ALSO
GIVEN THE URGENT CRISIS- WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRACTICE TLS ITS PROPER. SO
THAT PROVIDE CAN GET THE
FUNDING SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
OPERATE. GUARDING THE
TRANSITION. WHAT WE LOOK FOR TO
STAND UP FIRST WITH. ON THE
TRAY. FROM CITY D. F. WE HAVE
NOTICED THAT THERE HAS BEEN
LITTLE OUR WHICH TOOK. OF THE
TO PARTNER TO ADDRESS CONCERN
LOOK TOWARDS THE COURT AND WITH
DARK. JOHNSON IS THE DIRECT
WITH OUR MEN. OF THE GARDEN
MASTER. WE APPRECIATE THE TIME
PUT IN BY COUNTRY- WHO OPTED TO
MAKE THE CLAIM HOWEVER. ARE YOU
A MEMBER WHO SERVE THE EASY.
AFTER THAT THE WORKERS COUNCIL
OF LARGER THAN ACCOUNTS ITSELF
BY THE- WERE. IN A- THAT THE
NOT GO RUSSIA THE CURRENT.
CONDITION I'M UNDER THE WHICH
PROVIDERS ARE WORKING. TO
CONTINUE TO. WITH DAMAGE. AND
AND TODDLER. AND VERY LITTLE
FOCUS. AND I'VE LEFT GO- FOR. A
YOU FOR MUCH FOR YOUR COM-
MISTER MODERATE NEXT. TO CALLER.
THE COLOR COME FROM WIND FIFTY
FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO WE YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
OKAY GREAT NAME IS YOUR THAT'S
GOING ON WE I AM PLEASED. AND
I'M ON BEHALF OF OUR YEAH YOU
KNOW BOND AT ARE IN BY FUNDING
ME WE'RE REALLY I THINK. FOR
NEED A CHILD CARE OFFER RIGHT
NOW I'M BOB. MAJOR BEACH OUT TO
CARE OF OUR- CHILDREN AND OUR-
DON'T HAVE THE JOB SHARED. I'M
MORE CALLED FOR A FREE CALL PAY.
FOR PRIOR RIGHT NOW. MANY
FAMILIES CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY
THE RENT. I'M NOT NEED TO BE
FOR AFFORDABLE THEIR FAMILIES.
MINUTES MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT CALLER IS LINE
NUMBER FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ERICA ERICSSON
REPRESENTING YOU KNOW THEY'RE
BUILT UP CALIFORNIA A MEMBER
OF. THE BY THE AGENT WE
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN
EXPRESSED EARLY ENDED HEARING
REGARDING THE ABILITY OF
PROGRAMS TO REOPEN FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN WE NEEDING BACK. DELETED
INFRASTRUCTURE BY THE BUT IT
OVER YOUR COMPLETE. EIGHT OR
TWO HOW SIX THREE AND A BLACK.
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR A STRUCTURE
RENFRO. EVEN THOUGH WIND UP
WHAT WITH A- THREE YEAR ON THE
GOVERNOR EXPECTED TO. BY A CAN
I DO. IF IT BACK ANY GREAT IN
THE INTEREST OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
ARE YOU. LEADER ON GAP EARLY IN
THE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
PUSH COME OF MR MODERATE NEXT.
THE COLOR LINE NUMBERS EIGHT
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING- MORNING OF THE NINE
MISLED AND I GOT HERE. AND I
CALLING BEHALF OF COUNTY FOR
LATINO FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUST.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS ARE JOKES
PRESS SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL. AND
THE INTENT OF WOMEN. HELLO CAN
DO MORE TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
OF YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE AND
THEIR CHILDREN. AND SUPPORT
THEM AS HEALTHY YOUNG FAMILIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
TICKETHOLDERS ARE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY TWO FIVE TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THE LEAST
THE BANNER AND I'M WITH THE
BALLOT CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES NONPROFIT AGENCY
OFFERING RESIDENTIAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT CALIFORNIA
YOU. PROPERTY TWO YEARS
ORGANIZATIONS BOTH OF BOTH OF
THESE AND OUR BUSINESS ARE
LOOKING AT A VERY GRIM FUTURE
WHERE INVOLVED IN THE INDUSTRY
THAT HAS CHALLENGES IN. EVERY
SECTION OF ITS OPERATIONS.
CERTAIN ITEMS ARE BUSINESS
PEOPLE AND THEY GRADE THEIR OWN
SIGNIFICAN COST AND LABOR.
HOWEVER MY COUNTY IF THEY ARE
NOT CONTROLLING IN RIGHT THESE
FOR CLASS ACROSS AND BURIED ARE
THERE ARE CALIFORNIA OKAY
FACILITY THE ONLY IN EFFECT
BECAUSE HARD WORKING STAFF THAT
ARE CREATING. QUITE I'LL COME
MOST RESIDENTIAL AT. FACILITIES
ARE NOT COMPETENT WITH ONE. AND
COMPETENCE WITH THE K. THE
EIGHT TO REQUIRE AND THAT'S WHY
THE NEW. PER SUCCESSFUL TREE
PRO. I OF THE- AND- SENATOR
QUICK TO A FINANCE BOOK ABOUT
FOR ANYONE LET STANDING.
AVORIAZ OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS
ACTIVITIES HAPPEN FINANCIALLY
PERSONALLY. AND DESTRUCTIVELY
AFFECTED WE NEED YOUR HELP AND%
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. WELL NOT A LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT LINE
IS UP. GOOD MORNING ALEX TO
CAPRI ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA YOUR OPPOSITION HAVE
RECEIVED A COPY OF THE EASY
COALITION BUDGET LETTER WE
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLASS.
UNPRECEDENTED TURN AND CALL FOR
AN UNPRECEDENTED. YEAH IN THE
PUTTING. WHAT THEY LEARNING AND-
THEM THAT. LEARNING OUR FAMILY
WORKING AMERICANS. A MULTI YEAR
THE CALLER INVESTMENT GENERAL
FUND AB COMPREHEND FACT THAT
THE TRIPLE PAIR OF FORMER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AGAIN I GOT
ON GOING. IN FUTURE FERTILITY
AND INCREASE FUNDING. ELEMENT
AND END UP FORM FOR FAMILY
FOCUS SYSTEM. I TOLD HER. RIGHT
ACCORDING CALIFORNIA. HAVE DONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. STE
MODERATOR NAY CON QUOTE. WELL
NOW THE LINE NUMBER NAY NINE
ZERO CAROLINE IS A- GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS NINA TRACY
I'M REPRESENTING THE EVERY
EVERY HOW CALIFORNIA WE ARE
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT PROFIT
REPRESENTING FIFTEEN HUNDRED
SUBSIDIZED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PRO FIGHTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION AND
ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS WITH
THEIR REMARKS. SPECIFICALLY TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME ISSUES AS
RELATED TO THE HEARING TODAY
SPECIFICALLY THE INVESTMENTS ON
TO OUR HIGH QUALITY EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE
TITLE FIVE PROGRAMS SHE- STATED
BY CHERNOBYL MORGAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OUR HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS WERE ABLE TO STAY OPEN
THIS YEAR DUE TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS. EXTENDED TO PROGRAM
IT HOLD HARMLESS IS CRITICAL TO
KEEP PROGRAMS OPEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC OF THEY WILL BEING
REIMBURSED BASED ON
EXPENDITURES NOT ATTENDANCE.
DUE TO LIMITED CRITICIZED
DICTATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IT
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR THESE
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY EARN THEIR
CONTRACTS THIS YEAR. DUE TO
THE- CONTINUATION OF THE
PANDEMIC MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN OPEN DURING THE
ENTIRE TIME AS CHILD CARE HAS
BEEN DEEMED AS ESSENTIAL. THIS
HOLD HARMLESS NEEDS TO CONTINUE
THREE TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
ORDER TO KEEP THESE PROGRAMS
HOLE AND WE URGE THIS ITEM TO
ALSO BE INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY CHAIR BUDGET. ALSO
WAS NOTEDIN THE TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I LOOK FOR GIRLS. FOR
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. OF
MR MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NEXT
CALL OF THE AYE NUMBER NOW
THREE NINE YEAR IS OPEN. HELLO
CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CHARLES I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN COUNTLESS
FRANCISCO AT THE FAIR FOR THE
GROUP HE ADVOCACY COALITION
CODE SEVENTY TWO AFTER THE
ABILITY. OF MANY PROVIDERS HAVE
LEFT THE FIELD ARE CLOSER AT
THE- BACK BUT YOU KNOW
INDIGENOUS AND IMMIGRANT WOMEN
HAVE SUFFERED NOT. REQUIRED SO
THE EASY COALITION ASKING IF I
CAN PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING THE
NUMBERS IN THE GOVERNOR'S A
COLD AFFECTED. BY THE US ALEJO.
INDICATE A CUT OF CHILD YOUR
DOCTOR BETWEEN EIGHTY FIVE. AND
FIFTY THOUSAND. FURTHERMORE
CALIFORNIA CHILD BIRTH THE
PEARL IF THE DOCTOR. RIGHT AND
MY BAND HOME BASE PROVIDE OVER
THIRTY FIVE. THE AT THE TOP
HERE PROJECT ET I P. THIRTY
THOUSAND HOME BASE CHILD CARE
BENEFITS. WHAT THE END. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE- MISS MODERATE NEXT.
NEXT CALLER IS FROM NUMBER IN
FOUR NINE YEAR OLD IS OPEN.
TWENTY MORNING NAME IS
ATTENTIVELY THE HEALTH HOUSE
CARE WE THE PHONE NETWORK I'M
WEAK YOU ARE STYLE COULD BE
EQUAL NOT AS WELL AS- AND EVERY
CHILD HEALTH. I WOULD LIKE TO
LET STAFF- THE ONE PART THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY GET MENTION OR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS HAD SOME EFFECT OF BUILDING-
HOME BASED CHILDCARE. IF THE
CHILD CARE INITIATIVE PROJECT
AND IN FACT IN THE LAST ONE
BACK. HERE AGO WE WERE ABLE TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
HEALTHCARE. IN CALIFORNIA BY
40% I REQUEST IT IS TEN MILLION.
I'M A BEACH AND- ADDITIONAL
DAHLE AND THAT AND THAT. EXPECT
A BURKE AND THAT SPELLED WHY I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MR
MODERATOR NOW CALL. NEXT CALLER
SOMEONE NINETY FIVE NINE FIVE
CAROLINA OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BRINGING I'M- I'M A
COUNTY HOW AND HUMAN AGENCY I
AM HERE YOU HAVE COALITION THE
HUNT AND. THIRTEEN WHAT ARE THE
EIGHTEEN POINT ZERO FROM NEVER
AFTER YOU. ALMOST YEAH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR NEXT.
THE COLOR IS MEMBER HUNDRED
THREE IS THREE YOUR LINER OPEN.
M. OUTLINED HAS DROPPED OFF
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIVE ONE ZERO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A. B.
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF AT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AN
EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST. YEAH
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTERING POWER PROGRAMMING
I WANNA AGREE WITH THE
ANALYSIS- THAT WE HAVE SEEN THE
TWELVE ON. THE OUTSIDE AND
IMPACT AND THAT ON EITHER
SEEING MORE PEOPLE REMAIN IN
STAGE ONE AND THEN GET TO. EAT
IT ADDITIONALLY WE RECOMMEND
THAT EIGHT ONE NINE TWO PROGRAM
WITHIN CAL WORK CONTINUE TO BE
ADMINISTERED I THINK MOMENT
WRITTEN BY AGENCIES ARE PART OF
CAL WORKS. WE THINK THAT'S
BETTER AND SHARPER. OCT TO HAVE
A OF SERVICES FOR IN ADDITION
TO. AS PART OF THEIR WELFARE TO
WORK SECTORS A PATIENT THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER MODERATOR NECK CALL. AND
THAT WILL COME FROM THE LINE OF
ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS LINDA SUBTLE I'M CALLING
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK.
I UP THE FIRST ONE TO SAY THAT
I A LINE WITH THAT YOU SEE
COALITION RECOMMENDATIONS- FOR
IMMEDIATE DISBURSEMENT OF
FEDERAL. INSPECTORS NO NOT
TWELVE. AND IN RESPONSE TO
SUPPORTING OF STABILIZING AND
ADEQUATE SUPPLY. OBSTRUCTED FOR
PARENTS- I ALSO WANT TO ITERATE
REITERATE WHAT. THE SPEECH AT.
ABOUT CALLING A SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO THE CHILD CARE
INITIATIVE PROGRAM. WHICH THE
PROGRAM AND THAT TOO THAT HELPS
TO BUILD THE SUPPLY IN SUPPORT
OF A PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT-
BASS PRO. AND THE CC I. T.
PROGRAM IS IN EVERY COUNTY. HOW
CARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
AGENCIES- THIS PROGRAM DID
RECEIVE A ONE TIME TEMPORARY
BADGE IN FISCAL YEARS EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND NINETEEN TWENTY
AND RESULT IN A 43% INCREASE IN
LICENSE DR SPACE RIGHT- EIGHT
SO IT'S A DEMONSTRATION THAT
THEY CAN BE EFFECTIVE IN
SUPPORTING- THE SUPPLY FOR
PARENTS. AND SPECIALLY IN THE
TIME OF THE HAS CHANGED- YOU
SEE IT'S APPLIED THAT HAVING A
PROGRAM INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT PROVIDERS AT THE TRUCK.
BEFORE YOU DO THAT YOU. THE AS
ECONOMY WE BILL SO IT. SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM INVEST ACT
OF. THE SUPPORT THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS JUST REMIND EVERYBODY
TO MEET THE OTHER DEVICES SO
THERE'S NO BACKGROUND NOISE-
MISTER MODERATOR ANY OTHER
CALLERS. YES THAT'S OVER THE
LINE OF ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
KEEP GOING. HI MY NAME IS JULIE
MARQUEZ I'M A MEMBER OF PARA
VOICES AND I'M AWFUL SAN
FRANCISCO RESIDENT. AND I'M
HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR CHILD
CARE- IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT TO
FIND AFFORDABLE QUALITY AND
ACCESSIBLE CHILD CARE FOR
CHILDREN DURING AND THEN MAKE
AND- THE FLOCKS THIS YEAR
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR ARE MUCH
LESS. SO I WAS HOPING URGING
FOR FREEDOM FAMILY FEAST CALLED
THE PANDEMIC. AN ISSUE MUCH
MORE VOUCHERS TO HELP
STRUGGLING FAMILIES LIKE MINE I
THANK YOU FOR IT FINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. MISTER MODERATOR ANY
OTHER CALLERS. WE HAVE ONE MORE
INTO IT THIS TIME OVER THE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINE ONE
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MERRY
AND CHANDLER I AM ALSO CAR-
SPONDYLITIS OKAY. STILL I AM A
CAMPUS AT THE RESIDENCE. AND
THEIR SOCIAL WORKER ON THE SHOW
FOR THE EVENING AND I AM
ADVOCATING BUT CHAO CARE
BECAUSE- AND THEN MAKE I NEEDED
TO BE AT WORK. AND YOU AND I
NEED TO MAKE SURE THEM AND-
HAVE BEEN ACTIVE THE CHILD
CARE. IT VERY. FOR ME TO HAVE A
CHILD YOU KNOW FOR ME TO UP
WORK. ALSO I AM I. BECAUSE I
USE OF THE BY. AND GONNA SURE
THE WE OPEN MORE ABOUT YOUR FOR
THE FRONT BROWN WAIT LIST. AS
WELL AS- FAMILY FEES DURING THE-
BECAUSE WE ALREADY THERE ARE.
ON THE STRUGGLING. TO MAKE
MEANT. THE MORE MAY- FOUR TWO
ME AND MY HAS. THANK YOU AND-
HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU MUCH
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS-
MISTER MODERATOR THAT COMPLETE
EXHAUST THE QUEUE. Q. HAS BEEN
EXHAUSTED SIR PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH N. MISTER
MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ASSISTANCE- DURING THIS HEARING.
DO ANY OTHER SENATORS HAVE ANY
CLOSING QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ASCENDER EGGMAN LET ME JUST
ASK- WHEN WHEELS SUB THREE
RECONVENE IT IS CURRENTLY
ALMOST WE HAVE TO TAKE A HALF
HOUR IN BETWEEN FOR CLEANING SO
WHY DON'T WE START THIS HEARING
AT. TWELVE TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE AND THEN LET ME
JUST THANK EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WEREN'T
ABLE TO TESTIFY OR YOU WEREN'T
ABLE TO COMPLETE YOUR COMMENTS
PLEASE SUBMIT SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUSCA BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE'S
ONE AND THREE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE BECAUSE YOUR COMMENTS
ARE IMPORTANT THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANKS TO EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA SO THIS
JOINT HEARING. OF SENATE BUDGET
IN FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE'S
ONE AND THREE SHALL STAND
ADJOURNED.